[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm your host Greg Knuckles and
today I'm joined by a guest co-host Dr
pack pack how's it going it's going
great
um huge honor to be finally on the
stronger by science podcast long time
listener and big fan I assure you the
honor is probably not all mine but
mostly mine so I I figure uh a lot of
people listening to this already know
who you are um and for the people who
don't we'll do a formal introduction
once we get into the meat of the episode
um but for now what's on your mind do
you have any medor recommendations shout
outs or or other happy thoughts to get
the Good Vibes rolling uh shout out to
my mother the original doct Andre laki
for coming back from her trip to South
Korea where she educated the masses
there on everything education related
you know how U parents are with their
kids where they semi know what they're
doing but they don't know 100% what they
do mhm it's the same with myself and my
mother I know that she educates other
Educators um and that she has a PHD in
linguistics and she just came back from
a big trip so shout out to her that is
awesome uh congrats to your mom thank
you um for me uh my my little happy
thought to get things rolling is uh I
recently made maybe the best scones of
my life a couple days ago uh they were
some brown sugar and eggnog scones uh
it's it's December so that is eggnog
season um so if you would also like to
make brown sugar eggnog scones um I'll
I'll post the base recipe that I used uh
in the show notes it's from a website
called Sally's Baking Addiction and I'll
just warn you if you try to follow this
recipe it's actually not a particularly
good recipe um I don't know why I
continue using it because like it will
it will be way too wet like if you just
follow it verbatim like scono is
supposed to be reasonably dry compared
to most other doughs so like yeah it's
not a great recipe but like the first
time I used it I just figured out how to
modify it for my needs which is
basically just adding more flour until
the the consistency seems right so
anyway if you want to to follow this uh
just be for warned you will need to add
more flour but yeah basically I just
used that recipe as as the base subbed
in brown sugar in place of sugar um the
recipe calls for cream or buttermilk and
since they're brown sugar eggnog scones
obviously I used eggnog in place of the
cream uh and then seasoning wise I just
used freshly grad nutmeg and tonka beans
which uh fun fact about tonka beans pack
do you do you know what they are and are
they legal in the UK I do not and I'm
not sure so I'll I'll circle around on
on tonka beans again in a second um but
yeah so spice wise just freshly grated
nutmeg and tonka beans um and I added
some little miniature dark chocolate
chips as well um not a ton like not the
full cup to cup and a half of mixins the
recipe calls for like maybe half a cup
or so uh just add a little bit of
bitterness to cut through the sweetness
and uh they were very very good so if if
you're listening and you want a holiday
appropriate scone recipe to uh enjoy
this season I would uh I'd recommend
giving that a shot have you pulled up
info on tonka beans yet yep so from the
BBC uh um an article titled the flavor
that is illegal selling tonen beans to
eat has been illegal in the US
apparently since
1954 but uh in the UK I think they're
fine to use okay cool cool that that's
what I thought I think I think the US is
one of the few countries where they're
illegal but um yeah they're they're
really good if you're if you're into
baking like they're particularly good in
sweets they also pair well with seafood
but they have kind of like a vanilla
esque flavor but I'd say just kind of
like a bit more complex like if you've
had like fresh vanilla beans it's kind
of like the vanilla flavor you expect
from like a vanilla extract but it's
it's like it has kind of higher more
floral notes I would say tonka bean kind
of the base flavor is very reminiscent
of vanilla but then it's kind of like
deeper and warmer so it's just kind of
like it's a vanilla esque flavor but
like with a different inflection on it
and um yeah they they are illegal in the
US for just like weird regulatory
reasons so there is and I'm blanking on
the name of it but there's a chemical
compound in them that is a blood thinner
mhm and essentially like any any food
that wasn't a part of the us food supply
prior to 1954 I think you said it was
from the article um yeah anything with
that chemical that wasn't part of the us
food supply in 1954 is just like blanket
band um cuz you know it it thins your
blood it could have like negative drug
drug interactions could cause bleeding
problems theoretically but like there's
not enough of it in Tonka beine to
actually be dangerous and in fact um
like if if you've ever heard that
there's a compound in cinnamon that
thins your blood it's the exact same
thing and there's like a way higher
concentration in cinnamon uh but
cinnamon was already in the US food
supply in 1950 before so it got
grandfathered in and tonka beans are
still illegal so I had to find a
supplier in France that was willing to
ship to the US um but yeah if you're
willing to jump through some regulatory
loopholes in the US or I would assume
just go to your local supermarket
basically anywhere else in the world um
check out tonka beans if you haven't
already they're uh they're they're a
very fun ingredient to bake with
especially for sweets and they are legal
in the UK so I can get them off Amazon
there's plenty of different products and
varieties or whatever dosages I can get
but on the scone topic it's uh such a
coincidence that you're on the hype
train as well in my household both sweet
and um savory scones have been a major
hit the past few weeks with me consuming
up to four scones per day either with
jam and and butter or with soup and I
wanted to get your opinion on soups all
soups a bit underrated I felt like they
can be like a nutritional Powerhouse um
that people often sleep on especially
more like creamy soups that taste really
nice oh yeah I I think soups are
unbelievably underrated they're they're
very flexible like you you can make just
about any kind of soup and I I think
people who have a narrow view of soups
just need to expand their soup Horizon
cuz you can make hot soups you can make
cold soups um the just about any cuisine
you might like there are soups in that
Cuisine so they could be kind of bland
just like a standard like chicken broth
with some veggies in it or it could be
extremely flavorful cuz like what is a
thinner Curry except for a soup I mean I
can't see how that wouldn't meet the
definition of a soup but yeah man
they're they're excellent particularly
for cutting um like if you're trying to
lose weight I think they're super clutch
a misconception people have is that
liquid calories are inherently
non-filling because like a lot of energy
dense liquids are non-filling uh
particularly things you would drink like
sodas or whatnot a lot of alcoholic
beverages as well but the research on
method of consuming liquids is very
interesting so there was a study a while
back um that compared I think there were
three conditions I know there were at
least two yeah yeah I I think there were
three I think it was drinking apple
juice versus eating an apple with like
an equivalent amount of calories versus
uh eating apple juice with a spoon as
one would consume soup and the most
satiating of the three was eating apple
juice with a spoon um and so yeah like
that's interesting most like energy
containing beverages it seems like part
of the reason that they're not
particularly satiating is is just that
you can consume them so quickly um but
something that does have a pretty big
impact on satiety after a meal is just
like eating speed um so like the longer
it takes you to consume a particular
amount of energy the like to to a point
the more satiating it tends to be and
like soups can be really delicious and
not particularly energy dense um cuz I
mean they they are mostly water um
and so yeah they they slow you down like
a big old bowl of like you know chicken
rice like even if you're not adding a
bunch of added fats or whatnot might
still be like 7 800 calories like an
equivalent volume of soup might only be
like 3 or 400 and it's not going to be
that much less satiating especially if
you do eat most of it with a with a
spoon and you know like like slurp down
the the little bit of broth left at the
end but like not just uh kind of
make all of the mixins in the soup
really small just so you just put it in
a bowl and chug it um but yeah they're
they're really flexible flavor-wise and
I think like really really good for uh
when your calories are low and and
you're trying to stay satiated very
slept on yeah Pro tip try to eat it with
a with a fork and then you're going to
be spending hours and hours trying to
eat that soup that that must make things
even better for when you're cutting so I
realize your your verbal [__] posting
now but uh the Implement you eat with
there is also fun research on that um
like eating with a spoon or Fork versus
Chopsticks like even if you consume the
same amount kind of kind of on the same
tip like you just can't eat as fast with
chopsticks as you can a fork um and so
there's not like a huge body of research
on this but the studies that have been
done comparing eating with a fork versus
Chopsticks eating the same amount it's
just more satiating to eat with
chopsticks probably not doe to anything
about Chopsticks per se but they just
like slow you down so much it's a
similar concept but I think I think
eating soup with a fork might slow you
down a little bit too much but who knows
that's that's another topic for another
day that was the most productive uh [__]
posting I've ever done cuz I came out
not just having a laugh and enjoying the
joke but also learning a couple of
things so hey hey hey uh okay let's
let's push ahead one little note that I
want to make is that the next episode of
the podcast test will be with Milo wolf
um so if you're listening and you have
any questions for Milo uh email them to
podcast at Stronger by science.com I've
also posted some threads in the Facebook
group and subreddit soliciting questions
for both pack and Milo so let's uh
quickly transition into the plugs and
then we will dive into the content for
this episode so if you enjoy the show
please like rate and subs subscribe and
tell all your friends it really helps us
out uh listen on Spotify Rus five stars
on Spotify listen on iTunes Rus five
stars on iTunes say something nice along
with your review if you want to uh or if
you don't like the show that's also fine
if you're going to leave a low review
though at least like say something funny
about it uh that is always appreciated
if you're interested in hiring a virtual
coach to help you with your training and
or nutrition by science has an excellent
team of coaches that can help you out
you can learn more at Stronger by
science.com
coaching uh and in fact the uh co-host
of this episode Dr pack is one of our
excellent coaches um so if you like what
you hear from this episode that is that
is the level of Charisma and expertise
that you can expect from Stronger by
science coaches um and if you don't like
this episode the rest are are better
than pack uh not actually but that's
what you can tell yourself
um if you want to purchase supplements
from a reliable source and support the
podcast at the same time reliable and
and cheap Source um check out
bulksupplements.com and use the code SPS
POD at checkout for an additional 5%
discount off of their already low prices
uh if you're in the market for a premium
macr tracking and diet coaching app uh
you should check out macro factor and uh
I also just wanted to note on that our
label scanning feature recently came out
so uh if if you get annoyed when you
scan a barcode and nothing comes up cuz
it's not in the database now the app has
a feature where it will automatically
pivot from barcode scanner to uh optical
character recognition like using the
same camera as it's pulled up and uh you
just position the nutrition label in
front of the camera it'll pull all the
information off of the label so instead
of needing to to manually create a
custom food that might take a minute or
two now you can do the whole thing in
like 10 15 seconds from the time the
scan starts to actually naming the food
and logging it super fast uh very very
cool so uh yeah check that out and uh if
you want to learn more about the app you
can go to
check out uh mass or monthly
applications in strength sport um you
can learn more about that at Mass
research review.com if you want to stay
up to dat on all of the going on in the
stronger by science extended Universe
join our Facebook group and or subreddit
um and that's that's a good place to be
because if you would have been in those
places and you wanted to uh ask
questions for pack the the guest of this
episode guess what Q&A threads were
posted in the Facebook group and
subreddit and that is how you could have
got gotten your questions answered on
this show so if you hear the questions
and you're like damn I really wish I
would have had a chance to ask H join
the Facebook group and subreddit that is
that is how you get that opportunity if
you want to stay even further up to date
you can subscribe to our newsletter
where we send you highquality
informative content not just spamming
you with a bunch of ads you can check
that out at stronger by science.com
newsletter and finally uh if you have
questions for me or future guests of the
podcast or anything else um record a uh
one minute Max ideally around 30C voice
clip and email that to podcast stronger
byci
decom all right let's get into it um as
I mentioned up top today I'm joined by
Dr patrickus andreakis korakakis or pack
for short and uh pack my first question
for you is do you also go by pack to
other Greek people or is that just for
Americans and Brits that struggle to
site read the name of one of the main
characters from a foundational piece of
Western literature I do actually most
people refer to me as pack maybe my
mother and a few family members aside
but uh since a young age
growing up in Hip Hop and sort of
wanting to have my own tag and
essentially looking at how my mother
would write my name on like um clothes
and stuff whenever I would go to summer
camp so that they know you know like
pillow pillow cases and stuff my
initials are essentially P so then pack
became my sort of nickname and when I
left Greece at the age of 12 it came in
super handy because I went to Germany
and having you know Germans and even
Brits later on try to pronounce my
actual name name would be quite
challenging I mean even at uh University
documents I would often get it
misspelled which would often leave me
Bamboozled because I was like aren't you
copy-pasting the name from somewhere I'm
sure you have some some form of database
how do and it would be like seriously
messed up as well so I'm like this
person just tried to Freestyle it and
sort of prove a point versus just
hitting contrl C and control v um you're
talking to someone named Knuckles so I I
definitely feel your pain on that one
it's it's crazy crazy it's crazy
especially when it comes uh from like
off unofficial documents where you're
like I submitted a form for this how is
it misspelled um but yeah it's it's also
funny because I made a joke about
Patrick l being the lover of Achilles
and Troy which is not really a
historical fact but I made that on like
another uh on another video and there
were there were comments by Greeks where
they were like hey that's inaccurate and
you shouldn't say it and I was like bro
chill I'm just joking look I mean h not
to not to get too far into the Iliad
right now but uh given the mentorship
practices of ancient Greece I I don't I
don't think it's crazy to assume that
there was some subtext not that much of
a stretch um yeah there were the Greeks
back then they had certain practices
allegedly that would be questionable
with to today's societal standards and
what what's acceptable and whatnot yeah
I and and to be clear I'm not uh I'm I'm
not pandering with uh with some
anti-greek racism here which ah man
that's a that's a throwback to like the
the
1920s um but no I mean yeah it used to
be somewhat widespread and in other
places much more recently than Greece uh
you know there were there were some
young Lads on British Navy ships uh all
the way up to the early 1900s that uh
may have had a somewhat similar
experience to young patrickus but
whatever it is what it is um we don't we
don't condone that on the stronger by
science podcast but we also don't turn a
blind eye to history uh so follow-up
question there is uh if you had to give
yourself a homeric Epitaph what would it
be like kind of in the uh in the vein of
like Swift footed Achilles or Hector
break breaker of horses what is your
homeric epitaph
died for Achilles I guess bros
before hectors I don't know well it's
it's got to be pack something pack the
lover of Achilles yeah that works that
works
uh cool I actually I actually had um a
toy bunny that I still have like a when
I was when I was a baby that was
nicknamed Achilles fun fact fun personal
fact first heard on the SPS podcast that
is uh that is awesome my my little
stuffed animal as a kid uh and this is
100% true uh was a was a little pink rat
that I named ratty um what did you name
it ratty R A TT y uh I don't know why
instead of getting me a teddy bear my
parents got me a a rat but whatever I I
liked it you know um my my brother's
stuffed animal was a stuffed football uh
we had we had unconventional stuffed
companions in the knuckles house let's
shift into an actual introduction here
pack so uh for people who are unfamiliar
with you which honestly 20203 people are
still unfamiliar with you that's uh
that's that's a them problem but
hopefully we can Rectify that here um so
yeah tell tell the audience a little bit
about yourself um kind of your lifting
and academic background what what should
people know about you sure so I am first
of all a lifter and then an academic I
started lifting when I was 16 really got
into um strength training and a bit of
powerlifting as I reached my 20s and I
just fell in love with the gym and
everything that has to do with getting
bigger and stronger although I never
fell in love with either like power
lifting or bodybuilding per se I just
really enjoyed the the side of lifting
and breaking PRS chasing certain numbers
but not really treating it as a sport
more as a fun hobby and as like my me
time where I go to go to the gym do
stuff that I like feel tired feel
accomplished and uh leave as an academic
I've done my bachelors in uh Sports
Science actually in Fitness and personal
training which was which is essentially
Sports Science with some practical
modules here at soland University in the
UK then um through my Mentor Dr James
steel steel associate professor Dr James
steel which uh I'm sure some of the
people listening are aware of he got me
into research uh from a young age so
around 21 years old I started doing my
first uh lectures at the University and
uh working on a few research projects
one being um lower back strength in in
powerlifters via the isolated Lumber
extension Medics machine and I published
a couple of papers really enjoyed the
side the research side of things and
then I decided to skip the Masters uh
and do a PhD which ended up being on the
minimum effective dose I've been
teaching in and out of universities here
in the UK um for the the best part of
the last sort of six years or so and I
am currently a visiting scholar at Leman
College uh in the Bronx uh under the
grade wing of Dr Brad shenfeld where we
do a bunch of research on all things
lifting mostly hypertrophy and strength
focused and mostly research that uh
directly informs practice and is as I'd
like to call it research for lifters and
that's essentially my goal as an
academic I don't care to to be in
Academia and play the game of Academia
uh or necessarily make a living directly
off research but I love putting out and
and doing um research projects that
answer questions that interest me as a
lifter and can help you know at the pack
of 2030 uh figure things out and know
what to do better in the gym and what
not mhm so yeah that's that's that's me
and a nutshell I'm currently chasing a
300 kilo deadlift hopefully in the next
couple of months I'll get it um if I
don't hey ho you know it is what it is
where where's your deadlift at now I
recently hit a
287 and a half deadlift I think that's
634 okay nice hell yeah but that was in
jeans and completely unprepared so that
was a random session with poor sleep and
I felt like deadlifting and I managed to
hit that so I'm like okay maybe start
dedicating a bit more time to your
deadlift trading versus doing the odd
single here and there because that's
what I'm doing uh that's what I've been
doing at the moment so I was like okay
let's put a let's put a bit more
emphasis on actually deadlifting a bit
more so we can get the mighty 300 kilo
deadlift which has been a you know
all-time goal for me personally hell
yeah well good good luck on that you you
mentioned uh your your doctoral adviser
was James steel and uh you're currently
working with Brad now if you could just
like handpick to kind of like mentors in
this space uh those those are two those
are two very excellent people to to work
and learn under um so I I am uh I am
somewhat envious in that regard just
kind of like sticking with research for
a second um do you have any do you have
any ongoing projects that you're at
liberty to to share anything about sure
so we recently published a preprint on
optimizing uh resistance training
technique for hypertrophy mhm um there
is a regional hypertrophy um paper that
is currently in review uh if I am if I
recall correctly which I I am recording
correctly it hasn't been uh pre-printed
but it has been submitted for
publication um and it's titled exercise
selection differential differentially
influences lower body Regional muscle uh
development by the good uh Ryan Burke at
Al so the whole uh lab from Leman
College um is on this and this was a
project that was spearheaded by Ryan an
upand cominging researcher from um the
lab so that's that was a that was a
really cool project essentially looking
at the the leg press the leg extension
and the seated and standing calr mhm
there are a few so there is a
metaanalysis that I want to essentially
carry out but as you specifically know
uh it's probably a bit of a big project
I want to look at
you know do a meta analysis on p ratio
and and hypertrophy specifically but the
inclusion criteria for that would be
would have to be worked out so that we
don't look at every sort of uh study
that has looked at body composition
changes ever and there on the back of
the narrative review that we did on
optimizing muscle hypertrophy technique
for muscle hypertrophy there will be a
study happening in the Summer where we
want to essentially look at strict
versus more lenient technique and how
that influences hypertrophy there's a
lot of terms and conditions there and
things that I want to do in order to
make a study that has a sound design but
at the same time is ecologically valid
and so on and so forth um but that's a
project that this idea was by Jeff
nippard actually he he dropped the idea
for both The Narrative review and that
that study so the narrative review was
done in order to inform the methods of
that study and we want to look at things
like hey does external momentum um
affect let's say bicep growth versus
keeping things super strict and trying
to minimize that external momentum cuz
Believe It or Not aside from a modeling
paper that exists where a person try to
actually see if external momentum would
negatively affect adaptations U there's
nothing out there so my personal hunch
is that as long as you're working um
very close to
failure I don't see how things would
differ that severely I'm not sure what
you're take on that uh is H so with the
with the study itself I would be
interested in the
design um mostly with an eye towards
like generalizability because like I do
wonder if the type of exercise would be
would be relevant MH cuz like typically
typically you're using some sort of like
cheating or momentum to to get the
weight going and not all exercises have
like identical strength curves um you
know like some are hardest at the start
of the concentric some are hardest at
the end of the concentric and so you
know like like bouncing off your chest
in the bench press a little bit not not
just like fully using your chest as a
trampoline but like getting a little
bounce versus a pause like that feels to
me like that would kind of fall under
that umbrella um but that would sort of
help give
you that would sort of help give you a
more kind of even strength curve since
spinch does tend to be harder at the
bottom easier at the top versus
something like I don't know side delt
raises that are hardest at the top
easiest at the bottom like this isn't
like a strong prediction but like I
wouldn't be shocked like my my weak
prediction would be that um like
bouncing off your chest a little bit in
the bench press probably wouldn't
negatively impact PEC growth but like I
could see using too much momentum on the
delt Rays maybe negatively impacting
delt growth we shall see yeah we want to
also have one of the first studies to
openly share video footage of
participants doing the exercises oh nice
potentially um don't potentially I need
to see whether the IRB will be cool with
that obviously by still anonymizing
indivi the individual's identity and
also have maybe experts blindly assess
uh technique or rated whether it's
strict or lenient because I want to have
a study that is like ecologically valid
where we're not trying to essentially
standardize less strict more lenient
technique if that makes sense because
then that somewhat defeats the purpose
yeah and but rather use cues and then
have people say okay do you think that
was strict or not and then have that as
sort of our Judgment of whether um
technique was actually non-strict or
strict MH um ju just out of curiosity
like what
um are you playing on looking at
different kind of definitions of
strictness of technique kind of like you
know
being uh a little more forgiving with
form versus like using some body English
to generate momentum or are you just
kind of like going one way or the other
the thing is that ideally and now that
you said it as well I think we will have
to do it a dely study where we
essentially try to like formally Define
strict technique or what constitutes
strict or at least an interview and
Survey study with a bunch of like
experts so that could be coaches
athletes and strength and physique
Sports uh as well as personal trainers
and so on and so forth I think that
would help because at the moment there
wasn't there's not even uh a formal
definition for technique itself in the
literature uh which we try to also
propose in the narrative review that I
mentioned so ideally if we sort of
manage to formally Define what is strict
technique and then what's lenient
technique and is there a spectrum what
do most people regard as strict and as
non-strict then that would help but yeah
involvement of other uh unwanted or
untargeted muscle groups somebody
English but it's a bit tricky the the
design will take some time to really
nail but that's one of the study that is
in the works at least yeah yeah I I
think I think we'll probably dig into
this topic more uh later on in this
episode um but just kind of like one one
kind of like final thought that comes to
mind there for me
is
like a thought SL like something that I
find a little bit amusing which is that
like the idea of strict versus loose
technique I feel like does depend a
little bit on the perspective you're
coming at it from cuz like like Body
English for instance a lot of like
technique purist would be like ah no
like that's bad whatever but in terms of
just kind of like letting
uh joint kinematics shift over time um
like if you just dress that up and say
like oh no dude like it's a mechanical
drop set um y people people will then be
like oh that's uh totally legitimate
when if they thought you didn't know
what you were doing they'd be like oh no
like you're you're just not being strict
so for for people listening that don't
know what what that is like for instance
if you were doing dumbbell flies you
know you start with your elbows more or
less fully extended and then as your
pecs fatigue um you could go down and
weight like a standard drop set to make
flies easier or you could just bend your
elbows more and bring your hands in
closer to your body so if you just like
really wanted to absolutely crush your
pecs you could take something that you
like take a load that you could do 10 15
strict reps with with your arms pretty
fully extended for flies and as you
can't complete reps with your arms fully
extended anymore you just like gradually
bring the dumbbells in closer to your
body until you're basically just doing
dumbbell press if if you started with
the dumbbell press and called it flies
people be people would be like n that's
like shitty technique for Flies what are
you talking about but then just dress it
up and call it a mechanical drop set and
people are like oo that's a that's a a
very fun and uh intense Advanced
Training technique so yeah yeah I don't
know um that's a very fair point and it
it just goes to show how deep the the
rabbit hole can can get with technique
specifically and depending on the
circles that you you look at and the
recommendations that you hear there are
people that will really emphasize
certain cues and sort of kinematic
adjustments and emphasize them in a way
that conveys absolute certainty as far
as evidence behind those uh those
changes go and there are a lot of people
out there that do feel that oh if I
slightly change the way my elbow is
pointing in this exercise this could
have significant implications for muscle
growth for the muscle group that I'm
trying to Target but behind the curtain
of the literature is maybe like a like a
single posted note where you you'd
expect like piles and piles of papers is
like a little posted note that says
please check back
later you alluded to the The Narrative
review that uh that you pre-printed
recently so um let's just take like half
a step back can you tell can you tell us
a little bit about that um well I'll
I'll link it in the show notes so people
can find it but what's it what's it
called what were you interested in and
what are what are some of the takeaways
there yeah so the paper is called
optimizing resistance training technique
to maximize M hypertrophy and narrative
review and it was again a very this was
a truly collaborative effort because it
was a tricky paper to write um because
technique itself like defining technique
and its different components and then
looking like at exercise specific
kinematics and whether those are part of
technique and so on and so forth that
was quite tricky so shout out to the
whole team Milo who's going to be on
next Max Coleman Ryan Burke Alec Panero
Jeff nert and the good doctor Dr Brad
shanfeld um we essentially proposed
although there are some definitions in
like NCA books um and stuff uh or not
formal definitions but you can at least
like iner what a definition of technique
is by reading those books we propos that
resistance training exercise technique
uh pertains to the controlled execution
of bodily movements to ensure an
exercise effectively targets specific
muscle groups while minimizing the risk
of injury this involves the
orchestration of body positioning um and
Alignment as well as range of motion and
repetition Tempo so we broke down the
narrative review in different components
we looked at repetition Tempo and
although myself personally and this is
something I changed my mind on after
doing this this review I was uh somewhat
of a proponent of really focusing on
slowing down the Ecentric part the
Ecentric phase of a of a repetition um
because that's something that we hear
often you know even things like trying
to keep the Ecentric as long as four
plus seconds but when we look at the
literature the direct evidence really
making a strong case for slower uh
eccentrics is just not there there are
um a couple of studies that did show a
slight benefit to like when you looked
at four versus 2 second entric um but
overall there are other papers uh that
do show that a faster Ecentric may be
better than a slower one with some terms
and conditions there but overall the
data suggest that you can be pretty
flexible with repetition tempo as long
as your entire repetition is anywhere
between 2 to 8 seconds uh with some
entric control essentially not letting
the weight free fall but really milking
the Ecentric and really focusing on just
extending it more than than you feel
comfortable doing doesn't seem at least
based on the data that we currently have
it doesn't seem that like that's really
the case mhm um as far as range of
motion goes based on and I'm not going
to dig into the long muscle length
literature because I let Milo play his
cassette tape on that because he's the
the true expert I mean it's the same
with me and minimum dose it's
essentially like a pre-recorded like
little packs go in my head and they're
like okay minimum dose they got the
folder put it in press the press play um
but based on the current literature it
appears that utilizing a range of motion
that allows you to bias long muscle
length should be the default approach to
exercise technique when trying to
maximize hypertrophy although if you
were to take out the last part of range
of motion where you're working at Short
muscle lengths could potentially enhance
hypertrophy via different mechanisms and
you and Milo have written an insane
article um insane in a good way on the
stronger by science website U which I
urge everybody to check out because you
dive into all the potential mechanisms
and essentially arrive at a similar
conclusion where we like more research
on different range of motion
configurations is needed to draw
stronger conclusions um and at the same
time we don't have literature on Long
muscle length training specifically just
exclusively at long muscle lengths on
every sort of muscle group so it's as a
takeaway just make sure if you're trying
to maximize her pery to adapt an
exercise so that you can bias long
muscle lengths and get a really nice
stretch and as far as exercise specific
kinematics go believe it or not um
there's like one study on alternating
like U foot positioning and and Cal
hypertrophy mhm where they they actually
directly measured uh Cal hypertrophy but
besides that there's not much aside from
EMG data on like um grip width and bench
press and P activation and um there's
some stuff on leg press as well but
there's not a whole lot yeah I guess I
guess at some point there there is a
question of what would you consider a
technique variation versus like a whole
new exercise um cuz like one one thing
that does come to mind is there was that
uh flat vinch versus incline paper um
from maybe like three or four years ago
um which like yeah you could say bch
press and incline are two completely
different exercises but you could Al
kind of view them as variations on the
same exercise you know like that that is
I think larger differences than just
like are your toes turned in and out
doing calf raises but like is it that
big of a difference I don't know like
ultimately you're changing the angle of
one joint like now instead of hip
internal external rotation it's uh
degree of shoulder flexion um yeah I
don't know I don't know yeah I agree
and that's something that I tell a lot
of clients as well where they you know
they'll be like oh maybe I should be
doing more close grip bench pressing
versus slightly wider than close grip
bench pressing for to develop my triceps
or this or that or the other and
although you know preference is
important and if you do like performing
a slight variation more and it feels
better all for it I am of the same
opinion that you are probably not
looking at huge changes or huge
differences as far as far as muscle
hypertrophy goes assuming that you're
also doing other exercis for that muscle
group so as far as exercise specific
kinematics go um we essentially looked
at you know the origin of exercises and
sort of made exercise technique and sort
of explain how you know people just
logically thought okay I want to train
my quads my quads have this role
therefore I'm going to do this action
with my body and this seems to be
training my my legs it's not like the we
a bunch of scientists and said okay now
in we want to optimize muscle
hypertrophy let's figure out the best
exercises to do so for example the squad
first of all started as like a deep knee
Bend where people would bend their knees
but be on their tippy toes and then that
sort of and that was like back I think
in 19 in the 1920s or so and then that
sort of evolved to what we know now as
the squad but surprisingly back in the
in the 60s there were some preliminary
although methodologically not Super
Sound research that pointed at squats
being har deep squats being harmful for
your knees so exercise technique back
then was adjusted to limit range of
motion for squatting and then more
research came out and showed that that's
not actually the case so then technique
guidelines shifted from stopping at
parallel to squatting deep um so yeah
there's there there are a lot of
question marks there as far as takeaways
for exercise specific kinematics we we
highlighted that take the sort of
Universal um exercise guidelines on for
example how to perform a bench press and
then adapt those to the range of motion
and Tempo recommendations that were made
uh in the paper um because we we don't
really know if you know slightly um
widening your grip on the bench PR makes
a huge difference for PEC and tricep
hypertrophy lastly but not leastly um
there's no direct literature examining
the effect of strict versus non strict
repetition techniqu on hypertrophy and
although you could argue that the
involvement of other muscle groups May
negatively affect the hypertrophy
stimulus imposed on the muscle that
you're trying to Target it is currently
unclear as whether that's the case um
and yeah that's what we want to
essentially look at later so as far as
exercise technique goes if you're
somebody who's trying to absolutely
maximize hypertrophy make sure you're
emphasizing long muscle lengths keep
repetition duration anywhere between two
2 to 8 seconds with some entry control
and then it's volume and intensity of
effort that you need to to pay attention
at so things seem to be um relatively
flexible and you don't need to be an
absolute stickler when it comes to like
really controlling this Centric or
whatever yeah so I I I agree with
everything you just said um but I
wouldn't be surprised if some of the
people listening right now are a little
surprised and or confused to hear that
um cuz if you're you know if you're
consuming uh information in this space
you you would be very justified in in
coming away with the idea that we
actually do know a lot more about
optimal technique than than what you
just described um like I can understand
why someone would think that and um you
know mentioning that like hey we we
really do only have
one study kind of on on foot position in
the calf about like uh is is one ex like
is one exercise variation more effective
than another for targeting a particular
muscle um you know if you spend much
time on Instagram or Tik Tok or YouTube
um you you would probably come away with
the idea that there's there there's way
more research than that and that we know
way more about uh whether some like one
size variation is more effective than
another so would would you mind just
like explaining for The Listener where
that
mistaken understanding might might come
from if uh if someone listening to this
did hear what you just said and thought
like no that's like way too basic like
we we definitely know more about
optimizing technique than that yeah so
there are a lot of um Educators out
there who obviously mostly cater to
people that want to absolutely make
every educated bet they can even if that
bet is not like a large amount of
whatever I'm I'm not sure what the the
currency would be uh and want to do the
best in their ability to absolutely
maximize hypertrophy for example there
um coach [__] does a a lot of videos and
yeah workshops on biome mechanical
adjustments that you can do to exercises
that draw on you know um Anatomy light
anatomy and biomechanical principles and
are supposed to then better Target said
muscle group um and there's a lot of
content on that on optimizing exercise
technique because I feel that it allows
it gives people this sort of um
reassurance that you can you've been
missing out on this slight adjustment
that will highly potentiate your gains
when in reality it it is an educated
somewhat educated but at best and I'm
all for people trying to optimize and
trying new things cuz it can be fun to
play around with exercise technique and
be like oh you know what it feels much
better now that I I'm I've slightly
changed my grip on the lat pull down I
feel my lats more it feels more
enjoyable I'm still adhering to basic um
you know hypertrophy principles and I
like doing it that way but I I think it
all stems from our need to you know put
out more content and geek out over
relatively minute details which is is
what we're doing to a certain extent
with other topics as well but as far as
direct literature if you were to ask
anybody they would provide you with a
mechanistic rationale on why it may be
the case but at the same time there's no
actual evidence that those adjustments
do make a difference and I do feel that
a lot of people want to sort of make
sure and I get that with with clients as
well they want to make sure that they're
doing everything at their disposal to
absolutely maximize their time spent in
their gym but there comes a point where
doing more is not necessarily you
getting more out of it I'm not sure what
a what would be a good analogy here um
fueling your car more than you need to
putting more fuel in two two kind of
like directions I I was kind of thinking
about with this is um one just kind of
like what proxy measures are and like
how one would go about validating them
in the first place um for yeah like
attempting to make uh informed informed
bets or informed guesses about some of
this stuff um and the other is is yeah
kind of kind of what you were getting at
along the idea of of like
optimization one of the kind of like
mental models I think a lot of people
have um
that I think is understandable but I
don't
necessarily know how true it is um is is
just the idea that like dose like all
dose response curves are basically
linear yeah um exact where like you you
know it it very well could be that for
instance if you compare a standard lat
pull down to some like esoteric
variation of a lat pull down that like
theoretically biases the lats a little
bit more um it very well could be that
in a vacuum that esoteric variation does
bias the lats a little bit more but it
could also be that the hypertrophy
outcomes of lat training with respect to
lat biasing in an exercise are you know
like pseudo logarithmic rather than
linear such that like you know if if
you're 70% biasing the lats you're
getting the same training effect as like
95% biasing the lats and I feel like
often times that's just not considered
it's just kind of like if you're not
doing the maximal thing um W which I
mean I feel like there is research that
is like related to that to some extent
um like some of the like squat or leg
press versus knee extension research I
think is relevant there cuz like mhm you
knowe extensions are clearly going to
bias the quads way more than like any
compound lower body exercise like uh
like squats leg press clearly going to
train your quads very hard but uh you
know there are other things that could
be limits like your Technique could
shift over time to take some of the
stress off of the quads whereas with
knee extensions there's really there's
really no escaping it like your quads
are the only thing doing anything to do
a knee extension and like like knee
extensions do seem to be more effective
for rectus femoris growth
but seems like they're not any more
effective than squats or leg press for
like growth of the vast ey like your
vastest medialis lateralis intermedius
actually I don't think any of the
studies have looked directly at the
intermediat but yeah I mean you know
it's it's it's one of those things where
like I I I think that most of the ideas
that people have around like bias
exercise technique would prospectively
predict that knee extensions should be a
much better exercise for the quads than
squats or leg press but like the
research we have doesn't really bear
that out at least for like most heads of
the quads and so that that's what I was
kind of getting at with like the dose
like nonlinear dose response curves like
squats or leg press don't like fully
bias the quads but it seems like they
bias them enough you know yep and
surprisingly in the study that I that I
mentioned that is under review at the
moment leg extensions did indeed um
favor the rectus for Morris but leg
press favored the vas lateralis um which
was which was interesting oh nice yeah
and I think also like in the context of
optimization if you're somebody who and
again absolutely no shade at people
making optimization content and cool
we're lifting Geeks at the end of the
day and there's a lot of people that
have fun playing with different grips
different adjustments and at the end of
the day it's not costing you much to
slightly change your grip or whatever
and if you if it makes the exercise feel
better I'm all for it and all for
learning more about you know anatomy and
so on and so forth if that's what you
enjoy but if you're somebody who's
already on the optimization train
chances are you're performing you know
multiple exercises for uh all muscle
groups that you are training you're
performing enough training volume and
you're training pretty hard hard mhm in
that context if if let's say you were in
a scenario where you had to perform one
L exercise for the rest of your life for
whatever reason sure I get that maybe in
that context some slight changes may
make a meaningful difference but if
you're already doing you know two
different two types of pull Downs
different types of rowing and you're
training with a lot of volume and
pushing your training pretty hard I am
not very confident that you're looking
at many you know and meaningful
hypertrophy changes in the long term by
slightly adjusting your Technique here
and there at least at least based on the
current available evidence yeah no that
that makes sense that makes sense I
think exercise optimization content
annoys you less than it annoys me uh
honestly I'm trying to I'm trying to be
open-minded because this is the stronger
by science podcast not the muscle and
feels Milo I [__] posting in the form of
a podcast podcast oh no that that's
that's totally fair that's totally fair
yeah like it's it's not it's not that
I'm trying to be mean it's that like I'm
a I'm a crusty old bastard and what what
I mean by that is like I care a lot
about
epistemology and just kind of like
consistency of worldview I guess and so
here here's my thing if uh if someone
just says like oh like I I've never
looked at research at all I don't give a
[__] about it uh and like I train
bodybuilders and like ah here's here's
some [__] I do with them and like this
exercise [__] blows up your lats dude
like I have no problem with that
whatsoever um because like it is it is
like epistemically honest it's not
saying like scientifically this is the
optimum lat exercise it's just saying
like here's something I think I tried it
with some folks seems like it gets good
results you know like it's the the the
reason for that belief is clearly stated
it's like I thought this thing tried out
seems to be getting good results try it
for yourself you know may may give you
good results too the thing that gets
under my skin is when it is someone
who's kind of like presenting themsel as
like a sciency person and presenting
their approach as like
scientific um and I I kind of think that
if you're doing that you're like signing
yourself up for a worldview that should
be informed by scientific epistemology
and you know there there's a process you
need to go through to be able to make
claims like that in a scientific process
you know like if if you're using
something as a proxy for longitudinal
outcomes like that that acute measure or
like acute uh uh thing that you're
estimating there there should be
validation studies you know like you you
should bring some people in uh like
collect the data like measure the
variables um um and then look to see how
strongly Associated those acute proxy
measures are with the longitudinal
outcomes of interest and then uh just to
make sure you're not kind of like
overfitting or overe extrapolating from
a single subset like once
you've uh like on once you have done
kind of that first step of validation
you kind of like take the models you
develop in that first population just
recruit another population and kind of
run them through the same process and
see if the results hold up and if they
do then you can say like then you can
state with more confidence that like uh
Hey like we we have now
validated uh acute EMG as a valid proxy
measure for longitudinal hypertrophy
outcomes so then in the future if we do
see EMG differences between two exercise
variations of like this particular
magnitude we can say with some degree of
confidence without doing a longitudinal
study this one will probably get give
you better results than the other one um
but without that validation work being
done on the front end I don't I don't
think you should be allowed to do that
you know and I think you I think you
should take more heed if you do yeah
when things like that annoy me that is
what annoys me about it it's not like
the claims people are making it's that
they're like couching it in the language
of science but completely isoing any
concept of scientific epistemology and
like that yeah gets under my skin I get
it same here and we saw that we saw that
with even with EMG for example more
evidence came out in the last year
showing that it is indeed not a great
predictor of uh
hypertrophy um and at the same
time science is not as sexy as some
people want it to be where you're like
oh look graph yeah we're measuring this
okay there there's the answer I mean
even we just talked about excise
techniqu something that we consider
fundamental and we consider like okay
this is how you perform this exercise
where it's not really based on much but
yeah I totally get white grinds your
gears and I do feel that there are
people out there that do get overly
confused when they're exposed to so much
information out there especially
nowadays where you don't need to be like
a geek where you have to go in some
subreddit or you know some forum and
that's where you are exposed to to that
sort of information even if you're on
Instagram or Tik Tok it's likely that if
you're following uh lifters you're going
to come across videos that present
technique adjustments as really based in
science and for begin if I was a
beginner I remember actually when I was
a beginner I would look at certain
profiles and I'd be like okay things
seem pretty simple not easy but as long
as I do one two three and four for a few
years I'll be big and strong and then I
would look at other people and I'm like
wait I need to do seven different
modifications to these exercises that I
thought I was doing right and wow I've
been missing out on gains all this time
because I didn't do this and this and
that and thankfully um I learned more
and I realized that that wasn't the case
but I can totally see the negative side
of it as well yeah yeah and I and to to
be honest I'm probably a bit more
sensitive to that than I probably should
be um in in part just kind of due to the
makeup of our audience cuz like h a
pretty good chunk of people who follow
Stronger by science are like pretty
nerdy and like to get in the Weeds about
that and I think maybe more likely than
the average person to uh experience some
degree of like mental distress when
they're exposed to content like that and
they're like oh no I'm trying to do
everything right and like now this thing
is saying I'm not doing everything right
yeah what's going on and like yep I
don't know man like I I I care about the
people in the audience and like it's
it's causing in them some degree of
mental anguish and I'm like ah no like
this stuff is bad like it it it pisses
me off because it's it's causing bad
vibes for people that I like um you're
right but yeah I don't know may maybe
the people that I like are more
predisposed than average to experience
bad vibes when exposed to that content
so H I don't
know staying on
technique for a bit longer um I think it
might be worth talking about Tempo a
little bit more um just because like I I
think that uh the idea of like really
slowing down the Ecentric or just doing
slow reps period is maybe a little bit
less popular now than it used to be but
that that is still an idea you encounter
pretty frequently um so is is that
something you'd you'd have interest in
just talking a little bit more about
like what what what the research says
and maybe maybe kind of like why slow
tempo like at least like based
on would you be able would you be
willing or able to like speculate on why
slowy Centric don't seem to be that much
better for
hypertrophy yeah loaded question um we
can we can definitely have a look at the
at the literature and the current state
of evidence cuz it's not it's not that
much of a that much of a deep dive
mechanistically I wouldn't feel super
comfortable to do a proper deep dive now
cuz I don't think I'm sufficiently
prepared um to do that but like if there
was a there was a recent uh review that
looked at again 10o hypertrophy and
essentially concluded that so that that
was by wil atal 2021 that a combination
of slower Ecentric and faster concentric
repetitions seem to be best for
maximizing musle hypertrophy um however
even the authors of that review were
like look um the heterogenity among the
protocols of all the studies reviewed is
Is Not Great and the they said hey stay
anywhere between approximately 3 to 8
seconds per repetition but if you look
closely at the studies they cited for
the in support of slower and faster
slower Centrics and faster concentrics
they looked at a study by killer atal
from
2001 and uh noguera atal um 2009 and if
you then look at those studies one study
was um essentially comparing a five
versus a 4 second um
Ecentric and while prolonging the
duration of the concentric phase and
they found that prolonging the
concentric phase did not do much when
compared to a faster concentric phase
and they also did not directly measure
hypertrophy but rather changes in lean
body mass so a bunch of limitations
there and not and not really so that was
cited in support of hey perform faster
concentrics because the Centrics were
were pretty much the same they looked
they assessed body composition via botp
so that was one of the the limitations
and they also noted that all the
participants in that study did not see
any significant pre-post changes in lean
body mass and specifically state
that any changes in strength uh and
aerobic capacity because they measured
strength and aerobic capacity were
observed in the absence of changes in
lean body mass
so I wouldn't be I wouldn't be very
confident in just using that as as
anything more than H maybe yeah yeah um
and they then uh in contrast noal
demonstrated that a faster concentric of
1 second resulted in significantly
greater biceps uh and rectus femor
hypert when compared to slower
concentric phase that was uh 3 seconds
but that was also done in a cohort of
older men um if I'm not mistaken 70 plus
years old and then there were a couple
more studies one
that compared a 4C Ecentric to a 1second
Ecentric with a 1 second concentric in
both groups in the in the biceps but the
findings of that study by Pera ital in
2016 they showed no statistically
significant differences in hypertrophy
between the two groups but the effect
sizes favored the group that performed
the extending extended Ecentric phase
and yeah there's then there was there
were some studies actually that showed
that a slower Ecentric um sorry sorry a
uh a slower concentric so a 6sec
concentric when compared to a 2cond
concentric resulted in greater increases
in uh vastus lateral lateralis type one
and 2A fibers while the second second
ENT group uh only experienced increases
in vas vasus lat lateralis type one
fibers and any like the literature is
not really solid there's some
conflicting data but overall it's just
kind of all over the place all over the
place and that's like that's there's a
couple more studies but that's pretty
much it um so the next time like I used
to be a proponent and my apologies to
all the individuals that have worked
with me who did hear from me to hey
control the entric a bit more um but
extending the Ecentric more than a
couple of seconds doesn't seem to be a
game changer as far as hypertrophy goes
there are places for it and there are
cases where it feels more comfortable
and you're able to get a better stretch
and therefore bias long muscle LS more
but it's uh it's nothing magical why do
you think that uh that may be the case
there was a recent uh was a recent post
by meno as well expanding on the topic
I'm not sure if you saw that uh I I
didn't I mean I'll I'll be honest with
you I am I'm almost entirely off social
media these days which has been very
clutch for my mental health but then
sometimes I'll I'll just kind of like
peek in and I'll uh yeah I'll I'll I'll
see things where like I know I'm uh
waiting into the middle of a
conversation where like I'll I'll I'll
see something I'm like oh this is like
definitely definitely like a sub poost
uh about something else that someone
posted days ago that I didn't see so
yeah uh now when I get on social media
it is like more confusing than it's ever
been but no I if if you ask me did you
see a particular post the answer will
probably be no um but uh but yeah I I
think like the reason that I've heard
most frequently for why slower Ecentric
um would be assumed to be better um is
is just the idea that like eccentrics
are more effective for muscle growth
than concentrics and so if you slow down
the Ecentric you're going to increase
the Ecentric stress um like imposed by
the exercise
which I think you're I think you're
extending the duration
under which you are experiencing
Ecentric stress but you are to some
extent um reducing the intensity of the
Ecentric stress that you're experiencing
MH um cuz like the highest
forces um both like externally and like
internally in a muscle during the
Ecentric are at the end of the Ecentric
when you're like reversing it to start
your concentric um where you know the
the bar has a negative velocity and you
need to decelerate that to zero and then
you know start accelerating it upward
again uh or like bar whatever Implement
you're lifting um all else being equal
if the bar we moving eccentrically at 1
m/s when you're 3 cm from reducing it or
33 m/s when you're 3 cm away from
reducing it you're going to need to like
to like decelerate the bar to 0 m/s
you're going to have like that that
acceleration will need to be three times
greater if the Ecentric velocity is
faster like at that point in the lift
and so yeah with the slow Ecentric like
the 33 m/s you are spending more time in
the total Ecentric phase but then kind
of the the period of peak Ecentric
stress is going to be considerably lower
just because like your your bar velocity
that you then have to decelerate to
start your concentric is so much slower
um so to to me that just kind of like
there there are layers of assumptions
even underpinning that like you know is
the duration of stress or the total
intensity of stress more important
what's what are the dose response
relationships of those two variables
like what mechanistically is going on
are are you trying to reach a threshold
or is it something you accumulate like
yeah there there are a bunch of like
additional underlying assumptions even a
step down from that that we probably
don't have time to unpack here and even
if we did there's not research to unpack
to necessarily unpack all of those
underlying assumptions but just purely
just purely on kind of like a a onlevel
down perspective um faster versus slower
Ecentric to me seem like it's kind of a
tradeoff of duration of Ecentric stress
versus intensity of Ecentric stress
where the duration is obviously longer
with slower Ecentric but the peak
intensity of Ecentric stress is higher
with faster Ecentric and so to to me
just kind of on a baseline level it just
it just felt like that's kind of an
inherent trade-off and I wouldn't have
necessarily expected one to be way way
better than the other um so yeah that's
that's kind of that's kind of my
thinking on it yeah and if if you if you
even look at cuz originally I wanted to
have a section on the paper called
contraction type and sort of unpack why
like we include both the Ecentric and
the concentric uh why we include both
actions when we do a repetition and then
if you it's true that I I also believe
that a lot of people have sort of heard
or like glazed at the literature and
seen that oh eccentrics only are better
than concentrics only um and they've
looked at some of the literature that
has showed that but then there's other
literature uh like there's a review by
Frankie franie atal 2017 where they they
uh found that there was no major
hypertrophic differences when concentric
and Ecentric only conditions were
matched for overall workload which was
then contrasted by another study in
2018 uh but then further contrasted by
another study in 2022 so overall it it
does seem that Ecentric only training
can be quite potent for hypertrophy but
including both actions makes sense from
a practicality standpoint um but at the
same time the idea that concentrics only
are as Superior sometimes presented may
have some stronger terms and conditions
than most people um tend to think that
makes sense to me um one just kind of
final fun question before we wrap up on
technique and and pivot to the next
topic um
is do you have do you have like any hot
takes regarding exercise technique like
things things that just like fully you
know aren't refuted by the literature
but aren't supported by the literature
like like science has nothing to say
about them but just based on how
something feels to you or your
experiences as a coach is just like
something you believe yeah it it would
it would have to be um you know related
to injury and the idea
that certain adjustments to exercise to
technique inherently minimize like
significantly minimize the risk of
injury or that slightly deviating from
what we consider strict or textbook
technique will really increase your risk
of injury um if you look at direct
evidence on exercise toque and injury
you're not going to find anything um
there are some studies that for
example that have looked at human and
animal cavers and have argued for you
know spinal flexion uh Lumber spine
flexion and lower back pain at the same
time then you look at met analysis on
the topic and you see that that doesn't
seem to be a clear relationship but my
hot take is that as long as you keep
things relatively consistent and things
are feeling good you can do things that
look pretty pretty bad and we've seen
those people in the gym anecdotally like
we all know that one guy in the gym that
deadlifts with horrible textbook form
but he's still there walking and still
deadlifting so the hot take is that H
maybe it doesn't matter as much as we
think and your you know injuries are
much more random and somewhat out of our
control than we think I guess that
that's my hottest take yeah I I agree
with that um I am like a a chronic low
back pain person and so are you oh yeah
yeah um I I still don't know exactly
what happened but but yeah I like I I
injured my back at 16 and it's never
been right since um but yeah so so like
just just for my momentto moment pain
experience
um yeah like how I move is is like
pretty reliably related to that um but
you know there's a there's a difference
between kind of like my personal
experience uh of kind of like managing
ongoing injury related symptoms which at
this point May not even be injury
related it could just kind of be like
long-term sensitization stuff versus
risk factors for acute injuries and
currently uninjured people um yeah that
that was something that did take a while
for me to to wrap my head around though
just because like my my like individual
experience was like so suggestive in a
particular direction um yeah can't can't
generalize too much from that I guess
yeah and that that then goes back to oh
doing this hurts and doesn't feel good
maybe don't do this you know like cuz I
have the same with my with my shoulder
there are certain modifications my with
my left shoulder that I need to make in
order for things to feel good but then
you see people that will like heavily
criticize or catastrophize over slight
deviations and excess technique and feel
like oh I am like legit risking you know
being unable to walk or whatever just
because my back slightly rounded on the
or I didn't you know retract my
shoulders uh or whatever
mhm so I would urge caution there and I
urge movement optimism as the the the
the fellow Greg Leman I'm not sure
you're aware right yeah yeah for sure
yeah so Greg Leman I am possibly the
biggest promoter of Greg Leman I'm not
sure if he knows of my existence but
I've sent more people to his videos and
and work than probably anybody else but
yeah being a movement Optimist is
probably going to help Milo for example
is on the far other side of the Spectrum
where he like he got he hurt his back
one day deadlifting and Milo's a strong
deadlifter we're talking like 600 or
like six plates for reps on the deadlift
and um he hurt his back to the point
where he was like it was heavily
affecting his ability to walk and Milo
is not the kind of guy that will mistake
soreness or some like slight pain for
for an injury yeah yeah for sure and he
was like okay I'm I'll be I'll take my
time with uh with the loads that I lift
um give it a few few days to a couple of
weeks and then he was back to
deadlifting in no time I know a lot of
people that would have gotten MRIs that
would have gone to physios and that
would they would have thought that this
moment is a defining moment in my
lifting career and something is horribly
wrong with me and I won't be able to
lift like I did ever again which can
then affect getting back to lifting and
pain perception and so on and so forth
yeah okay so I I think that that's a a
good place to wrap up our discussion of
of technique we're going to pause for a
quick ad break and when we come back
we're going to shift gears and talk
minimum effective dose training so uh if
you're listening stick around and we
will be back
[Music]
soon all right welcome back to the
podcast uh still here with Dr Pac PhD uh
and like I said we're going to shift
gears and talk a little bit about
minimum effective dose training you you
mentioned at the top of the episode that
that was uh the topic of your doctoral
research um so yeah before before we
actually dive
into the the applied aspects of the
topic and the research on the topic I'm
curious just what what got you
interested in that topic for the first
in the first place like you could you
could choose anything for your doctoral
research
what uh what specifically interested you
in minimum effective dose training Y
super awesome question so when we
started with uh James the original idea
for the PHD was something along the
lines of like the main factors that uh
affect or at least predict powerlifting
performance but after doing like a
trying to do a literature review on the
topic I was like there's just way too
much there um to unpack and I would have
to focus on one uh key are and it didn't
seem that interesting to me at the same
time we had a very nice setup in Athens
Greece at the Olympic weightlifting Hall
in the Olympic Stadium the infamous um I
think there's a few solid weightlifters
that have come out of that ho long story
short deas baby de I said deas baby you
want a fun story about deus's brother I
would love any fun story at all related
to Pio deas one of my favorite athletes
of all time really cool guy and he's his
brother uh Odus Deus AKA odas Deus God
he is that's such a sick name yeah right
he is the I think he's still the current
um weightlifting coach for the Greek
powerlifting weight uh sorry Greek
weightlifting national team and um so
that weightlifting Hall was essentially
separated in two well in one third and
then 2/3 2/3 Olympic weightlifting and
then one/ third powerlifting in the
corner of shame um because weightlifters
maybe it's more in Greece but they don't
really look up to powerlifters like it's
considered as the you know the um the
wish version of of weightlifting because
it's not you know complex enough well
and you can win Olympic golden one and
not the other that's true that's facts
you heard it here first not really
you've heard it before it's a fact but
um that's a fair point actually
powerlifting debunked gone wrong I think
should be the the title of the the
podcast episode I I mean as as a
powerlifter I do think weightlifting is
just objectively cooler cuz like it is
it is they're still lifting such such
heavy weights but like you know I I
think I think almost anyone has at least
some degree of personal context
for a heavy deadlift you know like
everyone's picked up something heavy off
the ground and like maybe the heaviest
thing you've picked up is 200 lb you see
someone lifting 800 lb and you're like
damn that's way heavier than something I
could lift but like you still have some
mental context for it you see someone
snatch 400 lb you're like what the [__]
is going on there like that's that's
crazy and I mean weightlifters are so
they're so strong dude like I don't know
uh I mean obviously obviously there is a
lot of like speed and technique and it's
not just like raw strength but Ju Just
visually if you take uh like a a pretty
strong middleweight bencher and they
bench 405 you're like oh damn like you
held 405 lbs in your hands you pressed
it like it's very strong that's
impressive you see a similar Siz guy put
it over his head in a cleaning Jerk come
on yeah that's like yeah that's true
it's over your head it's way up there
like it's it's cooler you know and like
it's faster eh I don't know you know
what's what's missing it's the hype that
I think undermines Olympic weightlifting
cuz you see like some Chinese
weightlifting the guys there like 33 kg
in body weight squatting 250 kilos at
atg or doing some extreme snatch and
then absolute poker face no celebration
nobody shouting and you're like oh okay
if you don't know like if the weight if
the weight is not impressive to you
because you you you're not really
reading the bar you're just seeing some
plates on the bar you're like okay the
guy didn't seem that hyped about it it's
probably not that extreme whereas then
you see the guy deadlifting on Tik Tok
and he like the whole gym is around him
everybody's screaming and you're like
wow that was insane he managed to lock
this out H yeah I mean TR training
footage sure sure um I get Olympic
footage sure okay yeah there's more Hy
yeah I mean dude like inner
International weightlifting competitions
can can get crazy um and like I don't
know that that
could that could just be a matter of
kind of like the parts of the world
where the different sports are popular
like I I feel like powerlifting is like
more popular in more chill countries I
guess like if you compare for for
instance um like American basketball
fans to like Balkan basketball fans
goodbye oh buddy it's a it's a different
[__] World um it's a different world
indeed and that's one of the main things
I tell Americans cuz I've been I've been
to the stadium many times m we're
talking scenes we're talking flares on
flares we're talking things that are
shouldn't be allowed and are not but
it's it's mad I think at from certain
levels of resolution weightlifting like
the the the most hype weightlifting
competitions are more hype than the most
hype powerlifting competitions I think
by by a pretty comfortable margin fair
enough fair enough back to the story we
make we make we make a we make a a great
ad D do here it's been it's been amazing
cuz you match that energy and then I
don't feel bad about the about me going
off on a on a random story about Pius as
dima's brother so weightlifters snobbing
powerlifters to the point where there
would be times where people would tell
you to be quiet or stop doing what
you're doing because they would do like
a Max attempt the weightlifters the part
and um OAS one day walks in comes to the
to the powerlifting area on with
flip-flops there was something loaded on
the bench I think it was like a 110
kilos or something sits down grinds it
out for a single rep no warmup no
nothing but like proper grind puts it
back leaves um and also official review
of the CU they had like an AO power bar
mhm and he was like it's not a good bar
it doesn't it doesn't Bend much it
doesn't have much uh much whip uh so
that's that's the the anecdote there the
situation with the study was that we had
a good friend and the coach of that
powerlifting team panayot KRON is also
extremely uh well achieved musician in
Greece uh actually that's his full-time
job he's a buzuki player and he we
essentially had a setup which is
extremely rare for the world let alone
Greece where we essentially had a bunch
of powerlifters gathered there that we
could somehow in um control their
training so I was like hey how about we
try and do like a pilot study or some
form of study if they're up for it and
um they were up for it and we were like
okay let's just try um different like
protocols let's do like a traditional
powerlifting protocol in preparation for
Greek Nationals versus something on the
extreme end but on the extreme end as
far as low volume training goes so let's
just have them do very little like an
insanely low amount of training volume
and while thinking of that uh
study that's where the idea for the
minimum effective training those uh sort
of uh came to life CU I started looking
at the literature and I was like okay
what is the least one needs to do to get
stronger and as I looked there was no
direct um there was no paper directly
synthesizing the existing literature
there were no obviously there were no
studies on powerlifters training studies
specifically and I was like you know
what this may be the topic for the PHD
what's the least one needs to do what's
the least a powerlifter needs to do to
get stronger so essentially the pilot
study that ended up making it in the PHD
was what gave birth to the PHD itself
[Music]
can can you talk a little bit about your
PhD research um just kind of like what
you did what you found that combined
with the other literature kind of the
the implications for what it seems like
the minimum effective dose for strength
development is sure um so for everybody
listening aside from obviously the stud
is being linked below if you just type
minimum dose one word. trining in your
browser that will take you to a link
tree that has all the studies there so
the first three studies there are
essentially the entirety of my PhD um uh
they've all been published there two of
them are open access one is not but I'm
sure you can find ways to access it so
as far as the literature review of the
PHD um when I did the literature review
back in 201 uh 18 19 there was nothing
on on powerlifter specifically so I
looked at resistance strained
individuals there was no data on women
directly so I ended up looking at at
resistance trained men and we found that
performing a single set of 6 to 12 reps
with loads ranging anywhere from 70 to
85% of one's one repetition maximum uh
strength performed two to three times
per week reaching volitional or
momentary failure um can lead to
suboptimal yet significant uh increases
in both Squat and bench press 1rm
strength um because there was no data on
the deadlift so that's essentially like
for General sort of it was for one
repetition maximum strength but we
didn't look at a um a population of
powerlifters there so then we performed
well we had actually performed the pilot
study um at a similar time where we had
a bunch of people perform just less than
a handful of singles per powerlift per
week so they were doing one single per
week for the deadlift obviously
including their warm-ups and um three
singles per week for the bench press and
two singles per week for the squad
training three times per week with a
squad bench deadlift frequency of
231 and this was a bit of a tricky study
because they prepared and they got
tested not in a lab or the hall or the
training training facility but rather we
used their H pre-training Training hall
numbers so their their testing session
numbers and compared them to what they
achieved in at Greek Nationals and as
many of the listeners of the podcast are
aware um competing and putting up
numbers in a competition is a much
different story than doing so in your
like regular gym environment what we did
see though is that out of the the few
people in the group that did just the
singles the four out of five people
managed
to like surpass their their training
total um during training and some um did
okay at competition saw some increases
some decreased and one maintained but
the fact that they're par training
results cuz that study was 10 weeks long
hinted at the idea that hm maybe you
could go as low as doing a few singles
per week so then we did a bunch of
studies to see whether that's true or
not and um those were published as one
paper which you are also u a co-author
on ye yes and uh Ju Just to uh slightly
apologize and give context for something
I said um it may have sounded like I was
like being slightly dismissive like ah I
don't go into too much excruciating
detail here um not because I I don't
want you to be able to describe your
research in whatever depth you see fit
but it was because I was an author on
that paper and it's a long [__] paper
it's a long bro H you a nobody go time
for that I mean the listeners here the
listeners here like long episodes but I
figure we probably shouldn't push it
another two hours um so yeah that that
is what I had in mind when when I said
that uh it's a very it's a very fair
comment because and I think a lot of
people have missed out on the fact I
think this was one of the first um multi
experiment papers in sports science in
Psychology it's more common to see
multi-experiment papers shout out to
James steel that was that was his idea
and essentially what we did here was we
did one interview study with very
experienced coaches and athletes so I'm
talking about like some of the best
powerlifters in the world regardless of
um Federation sex or age as as well as
many experienced coaches with like tons
of NA ipf national and world champions
under their belt um when we essentially
explored the concept of the minimum dose
we asked them hey have you played around
with the concept what do you think is is
possible as far as strength increases in
in certain periods of time what's the
least one can do um we also did a couple
of studies where we had people perform
um single just singles like we did in
the pilot study uh then we had a group
perform singles and and a couple of back
off sets um and we also asked nationally
qualified ipf powerlifters about their
experiences with minimum dose training
in the form of a survey as well as try
to Define what meaning what what a
meaningful strength change constitutes
so you were right to say that hey
unpacking this would we take a long time
and we would because we would have to
essentially review five studies but
overall after we triangulate all
the data that we that we collected
including the interview and the
intervention studies we found that
powerlifting athletes looking to train
with a minimum effective training dose
approach can do by doing uh three to six
working sets of around one to five
repetitions each week with those uh sets
spread across one to three sessions per
week per powerlift using loads somewhat
above 80% want a Ram at an RP of
somewhere between 7.5 to 9.5 for around
6 to 12 weeks and expect to gain
strength if you were to go as low as the
people in the pilot study and just do
like literally one to three singles per
week per powerlift your chances of
making meaningful gains are quite quite
lower um and it's likely that you won't
make meaningful gains but you could
experience meaningful gains just by
adding two to three backup sets at 80%
of whatever you hit for a single
repetition anywhere around 80% uh and
expect to probably surpass what coaches
and powerlifting athletes regard as
meaningful so things are looking really
good for people that are pressed for
time or want to you know um not spend a
ton of their recovery resources in their
training for whatever reason yeah that
that makes sense um the follow-up
question to that that that I've always
had at least is how um
how generalizable through time do you
think that is you know like these these
are findings
over weeks yeah like six weeks and and
you know like I'm I'm not I'm not trying
to ask you to just like hype up your
research or over interpret it like this
is this is mostly just kind of like a
Vibes based question like based on your
experience as a lifter and a coach um
the idea of just like a few Singles Plus
back off sets per week um how long do
you think that would actually lead to
like productive strength increases like
do you do you think that the findings
may have to some extent been an artifact
of the six- we training blocks or do you
think that if uh if you push that out to
like four months people still would have
been making gains at four months yeah
that's an interesting question and that
was I think one of the limitations that
we didn't discuss in detail um on the
paper like and it's one of the questions
of one of the the viewer the listeners
as well could it have just been PE
peaking you know six weeks of very
specific powerlifting training sort of
acting as a peak um and although yes
that may explain the results to a
certain extent
anecdotally um when the research came
out a lot of people reached out and said
hey this is really cool I did something
similar for a couple of months uh even
even longer than a couple of months back
in the day but if were're to triangulate
and that's why we spoke to coaches and
athletes um and experienced coaches and
athletes to see whether you know what we
found sort of lines up with their
experience um and it more or less did
with with uh the the 12we figure coming
out of the of the back of the interviews
rather than the intervention data so I'd
say that my bet will expressed with
caution and based on the literature but
also my personal experience as a coach I
think you could do as little as 3 to six
working sets uh per power lift per week
spread across one to three sessions uh
for 3 to four months and still make make
gains now there are other factors that
will come in play like your experience
um how much M Mass have you you've
you've built technical proficiency and
so on and so forth but it's not like you
will know the thing if you're training
with singles you after like a few weeks
of things not looking that great I think
it's you you'll get you'll get the heads
up from your training feedback pretty
quickly to know that things may need uh
a different push but then the question
becomes how much more do you need to add
to still see progress because it could
be that if you add another set or two
you can still just like keep going for
another couple of months and then you
know same o same um but i' say with some
certainty 3 to four months should be
should be more than enough for you to
make meaningful strength gains based on
uh powerlifting um uh standards yeah I I
I I agree with that honestly um I don't
know I I think I think the way someone
views that will probably be so filtered
through the lens of their own experience
that I do question the generalizability
like I I think that what you outlined
would probably be a pretty productive
long-term approach to training like
Beyond 6 weeks um but that is heavily
informed by the fact that that type of
thing has been pretty successful for me
for periods longer than six weeks um and
I I imagine if that had not been the
case for someone else they'd be like n
you're full of [__] so yeah but that
that that would be uh that would be
something I would be interested in
seeing more research on in the future um
same and not just on this research topic
I mean almost everything like if if you
can if you can get 12 weeks out of a
training study like you're doing pretty
good for yourself um and like ah 3
months just isn't that long in the
context of like a 10year training career
like with with so many topics in the
research I'm like ah just how would it
look at six months how would it look at
a year you know wouldn't it be nice if
like we got like if I think if somebody
decided like a millionaire like a multi
multi-millionaire was like okay let's
answer some fundamental questions that
we have about muscle building and
strength here's a few Millions do the
studies don't you think like if we had
that money in like a couple of years we
could answer a lot of big questions I
think we could do it now honestly I
think that
um so all right one of the issues is uh
like subject Recruitment and Retention
um and and just purely a matter of like
who's going to run the training visits
cuz is like more than people realize
science is largely done by grad students
on grad students and so you know there
are summers there are like winter breaks
um for master students they're in the
program for two years they're pretty
worthless for the first semester so
there's some like training time to get
them up to speed so you know all of
those things and and like a lot of the
subjects will also just be undergrad
students so you got like if if you start
a study on the first week of classes
like you can do 16 weeks before finals
um but yeah so the if you wanted to do a
long-term training study it would be
challenging to find enough
people in proximity to like a particular
lab to say like oh yeah like I'm going
to sign on for two years like you can do
my training for 2 years and then even if
you could like people's minds change and
a pretty good chunk of them would
probably drop out um and maybe you could
keep them around and I I think this may
to some extent be what you had in mind
with like a rich person funding this
like ah maybe maybe you could recruit 50
subjects in a single City to handle
their training for two years if like
you're going to pay them five 10 grand
at the end of it um but like yeah H then
it gets really expensive and I don't
know how this would be in other
countries the US you you still might not
be able to get that by an IRB cuz like
that's true you get in trouble for
paying people too much because it could
be seen as like coercive and potentially
taking advantage of people who aren't as
economically advantaged so yeah so I I
think I think a lot of that is like kind
of a non-starter but here's here's
something I I wish existed and could
exist uh someone would just need to do
quite a bit of like work if there was
more um like crosslab collaboration on a
lot of this stuff like I I think it
would be hor horrendously difficult to
find enough people for enough
statistical power to run a one-year
training study at any single lab um
outside of community dwelling older
adults you see some long-term studies in
them but pretty much no one else um but
yeah like you you know Finding 20 30 40
people eh like it's it's just not going
to happen but I don't think it's
unlikely that multiple Labs could find
like one or two people you know and then
if you had collaboration between like 20
different labs and the the training
burden and the data collection burden
for each individual lab is like
exceptionally low you know you just have
one or two people coming in three four
times a week like with like with all of
the other data collection you're doing
like that would just be a drop in the
bucket TimeWise and then then like you
know on the back end you might need to
like statistically control for like lab
effects cuz like H like some Labs just
may across the board tend to see more
robust training effects than others like
there there would there would be some
like analytical
concerns like like not not hurdles that
would be unclearable but H like your
statistical approach to analyzing the
data would would need to be a bit more
sophisticated than a typical study but
ah like I don't know I do think that
would be pretty feasible
um but like most of the work would be on
the front end to just like build the
network of scientists who would be like
willing and able to collaborate on
projects like that but I think if you
distribute it enough it would be like
very feasible yeah and that's something
we've we've tried and we're currently
trying to to do that was again like
James's influence was was heavy on that
like multide data collection then the
issue though becomes like if you have
people who are deep into Academia as
their career there's other fact factors
that come into what studies they can run
how many people they can they can use
what they can prioritize but I do agree
that that's where the field should start
moving towards and having maybe like a a
body or I don't know like a an
organization that sort of handles
handles multisite data collection or
something that could that could
definitely help us answer more
questions um
yeah just get back to minimum effective
dose stuff two other questions I have
with that and then I think we can kind
of like wrap up this segment and and
answer a few questions the first is um
anytime this question comes up you're
you're going to see people just being
like like why should we care about this
in the first place you know like I'm
trying to maximize my gains like why why
am I trying to find the minimum volume
to still make some gains um or they
might even come in with like negative
inference it's like ah like this
person's just trying to like trick
people into being lazy and like sell
them like like you know gains with no
effort um so I do think it's worth
talking a little bit about like why
people should care about this in the
first place and and I'm not saying that
as kind of like a gotcha like leading
question I think there's like very clear
reasons that people should care about
this but yeah like like why should we
care what the minimum effective doses
for strength gains like who might this
be like extremely useful and relevant
for Imagine though if I was actually
caught off guard here and and it was a
true gotcha moment and I was like
um I gotta go um in all seriousness um
the thing is a lot of people if not the
not not a lot the majority of people
that engage even in strength Sports and
strength training as a hobby um have
lives have other priorities professional
family related and so on and so forth it
is almost impossible that you will not
have periods during your life where
stress is very high um time is off the
essence and also mood to train is not
there we love lifting but I'm sure
everyone even the most hardcore lifters
here do go through you know those odd
couple of months where excitement to
lift is just not there and having the
minimum effect the concept of the
minimum effective dose and knowing that
you can always fall back to doing less
and still seeing meaningful strength
increases because keep in mind we didn't
look at what's the least you need to do
in order to maintain your strength or
just see some slight change in the
numbers um having that concept can allow
you to still remain productive during
periods where other times you you could
could have been um not training because
you would go ah yes I cannot do my 15
sets of squats this week um I'm going to
skip Session One um I missed out on
session one might as well miss session
two and so on and so forth whereas now
you get sort of um a reassurance tap on
the back from Big minimum dose where
minimum dose comes there in the form of
a person that says hey bro or sis worry
not you can still make great gains for a
short period of time and in the long
term um those few weeks where you did
less training volume are probably not
going to matter that much for strength
development at the same time I would
also argue that
maximizing strength and hypertrophy is a
long-term game so finding ways to stay
to adhere to lifting consistently is
what truly allows you to maximize versus
viewing progress as this sort of
shortterm um short-term sort of concept
where it's like okay optimal training
volume is this I will always need to be
doing that but rather if pack if we have
two clones of me and pack a is always
trying to optimize which causes him to
either miss out on sessions or
potentially push training harder than he
needs to during periods where sleep is
limited or whatever and then that ends
up you know H ends up with him having to
Deo or potentially getting injured or
whatever versus pack B who is trying to
maximize adaptations for the majority of
time and when not possible is still
trying to get the best uh that he can
under those circumstances uh from his
training I think that pack B will have
better chances at longterm term
maximization of uh outcomes plus um
starting having the minimum effective
dose as your starting point can be a
great way to build over time and just
sort of see whether you actually need
more um to get stronger because for some
people it may be that they are doing way
more than they actually need to see uh
increases that they're interested in
yeah I I think I think that makes a lot
of sense uh and in fact like several
other like pretty common scenarios also
like immediately come to mind for me um
it's like my my start with coaching was
in coaching like team sport athletes
versus strength athletes specifically
and like this is like these types of
things are huge for them because if
you're an inseason basketball player or
an inseason football player like you're
not like you don't have the ability to
train as if you're trying to maximize
strength or power development like you
are mostly just trying to maintain or
you know if you can still like gradually
build throughout the season versus your
Rivals who maybe are like gradually
getting a little weaker like maybe team
performance improves because like you
get more practices under your belt
better tactics ah whatever but like like
physically in a lot of sports it's not
uncommon for players to be like at their
Peak first week of the season and then
like slowly degrade over the course of a
season and so knowing that it doesn't
take much to not even just maintain but
like slightly improved performance um is
is pretty clutch for a lot of athletes
uh another thing that comes to mind uh
even for people who are like big on the
optimization train is just like you
can't necessarily push super hard on
everything all the time um and so like
knowing minimum effective dose
for you know individual lifts can help
with like specialization Cycles like one
of one of the things that I always found
with my squad and deadlift is like I
couldn't push both hard at the same time
like I've like when very early in my
training career sure like I could PR my
squad and deadlift at the same time but
I I honestly can't remember a time after
I was like 17 years old that I pr both
my squad and deadlift at the end of a
training cycle and so like I would just
need to alternate between the two and
just kind of like keep one on like a
minimum effective dose or maybe even
like a step below that kind of like a
maintenance dose um and just like really
push the other and so you know I I don't
think that's like too terribly uncommon
um you know put putting other things on
the back burner while not regressing to
be able to like really push something
else um and then also
like one of like the the largest
population of people that engage in
resistance training um or what public
health bodies would call like muscle
strengthening exercise aren't lifters um
like this is uh this is something that
oh man I forget the exact numbers but
hopefully I'm not that far off um
something like
35% of Americans and somewhere between
like 20 to 40% of individual idual in
like most developed countries meet
government guidelines for like muscle
strengthening exercise um which could be
lifting could be you know like Pilates
or uh at home like circuit training or
whatever but like you know it's
um more people are
doing uh some form of resistance
exercise than I think a lot of folks
realize but it's still like a minority
of the population and in surveys when
you ask the 60 to 80% of people who
aren't doing that hey why not um time
constraints are cited as a really major
concern and so knowing that it it
doesn't take that much to like even even
for like trained powerlifters to get
stronger and make gains like I have to
assume the minimum effective dose for
like a completely untrained person who's
done no resistance exercise size at all
would be even lower so know knowing that
like like if you only have 30 minutes
per week to do some sort of resistance
exercise that like that is still like
productive and like it's going to be
good for your health but it it's also
for a lot of people going to be enough
to actually make them stronger maybe
change like maybe allow them to see some
physique changes as well although
strength hypertrophy like two slightly
different things like but yeah just
knowing that you don't have to do that
much to see positive effects I think is
something a lot of people don't realize
and I think we would live in a somewhat
healthier Society if more people did
realize that cuz cuz folks think that
like hey if I'm going to do some sort of
like resistance exercise the only folks
that I I know who do that are like ah
like my my nephew who's like big into
bodybuilding but like he's in the gym 10
hours a week I don't have time to go to
the gym 10 hours a week so just like
[__] it I'm not even going to try yeah
yeah like I I I think that this approach
could and I think maybe even should be
the default approach for most people
most of the time like not necessarily
competitive powerlifters but just like
humans that exist yep um and so I think
it's I think it's like incredibly
valuable on that front yeah yeah I mean
like you SBS has covered this um and in
detail so the the paper by sh Shandra
atal U so resistance training and
mortality risk a systematic review and
meta analysis where they essentially
noted that hey any amount of resistance
training can lead to can reduce all CA
mortality by around 15% and
cardiovascular disease mortality by 19%
and cancer mortality by 14% with maximum
reduction risk reduction being achieved
at around 60 minutes and it's like yeah
you're you're 100% spot on with more
like the majority of people would
benefit more from the concept of the
minimum effective dose um than your
average you know powerlifter bodybuilder
who's trying to maximize gains but it's
a concept that holds a lot of value for
them as well and Hey Nobody's telling
you that's all you should do forever
yeah I think the final question I have
on this uh before before we we shift to
Q&A
is and and this might be more of a Vibes
question than a research question um
vies but how how do you think minimum
AFF dose changes throughout a training
career like do you think that it just
gradually increases as training status
increases or some some other uh type of
arrangement um based on the fact that
the numbers like as far as like weekly
sets per week are somewhat similar in
studies where you have you know
untrained individuals then resistance
trained then you have powerlifters given
that those numbers are you know like a
handful of sets like say on average a
handful of sets per lift per week seems
to seem seems to do the trick as far as
meaningful gains go I wouldn't expect
and based on the interviews as well
because keep in mind when you hear
alltime world record holders tell you
yeah I used to do a couple of sets for
my squad per week and hit a PR um my
sort of belief My Vibes um shifted from
thinking that maybe as you get more
advanced you your your minimum effective
dose is somewhat larger um and I think
that for the majority of of people
regardless of level the starting sort of
numbers are somewhat the same so now
over time as you're getting used to very
low training volumes I do think because
like volume and strength don't have at
least don't appear to have the same
relationship as hypertrophy but more
will be better after a certain point um
so I do feel that there comes a point
where that minimum effective training do
changes and you'll have to add a bit
more volume and keep in mind adding a
couple of sets may not seem like much
but if you look at it as a percentage
increase you could be looking at you
know 200 to 300% more volume than you
were doing before if you were doing just
a few sets um but yeah I'm not entirely
sure as to how that changes over time I
would expect that it comes a point where
you plate you need to do more but where
when that happens is something that we
we still need to figure out and
obviously like strength itself over time
like we recently published a paper call
called using powerlifting athletes to
determine strength adaptations across
ages in males and females a longitudinal
growth modeling approach this was peer
headed by Christopher latella and myself
and Milo had the chance to help out I
read that paper I enjoyed it um nice
it's for you only I think it's you and
us that have read at the moment I I mean
I I don't know uh yeah I the the the
linear log curves I think were probably
a good choice for modeling it um but the
the the implication for for ongoing
gains past a certain point is is
relatively Grim um it's Grim that's what
I was going to
say like cuz it's like hey early like
first couple of years like first year
actually of powerlifting obviously keep
in mind when people start powerlifting
they've obviously seen a bunch of gains
until they've started powerlifting so
take that with a grain of sold like you
see 7.5 to 12% increases from Baseline
in terms of like total powerlifting
strength in the first year and then
you're looking at not an additional 20%
but like an
additional maybe 12 at most or
7.5% after 10 years and there comes a
point after your age where you're
starting to see declines in strength
strength and that's something that I
tell some clients as well especially
experienced powerlifters where they're
like my bench has been stuck for a few
years and they they have this idea that
you know I'm all of a sudden going to be
adding 30 and 40 pounds on that bench
and unfortunately you have to manage
expectations and be like look if you
don't do anything drastic with uh your
body weight or change something
extremely um or change something that
you hadn't been doing as far as training
goes it's likely that things are just
slowing down over time
so it is the name of the game and in the
context of the minimum dose there will
come a point in general where you won't
be able to see great strength increase
so it may not be that the minimum dose
that you had is ineffective it may be
that no matter what you do eing out a
few more kilos on your bench or squad or
deadlift is going to take a long time
and a lot of consistent training yeah I
think that that is an important point
just like the idea that like uh
necessary training volumes um like
necessarily just like gradually increase
over time like that is a pretty popular
idea um but I'm not like I I definitely
used to believe I'm I I think I believe
it less and less these days um but I I
think I think where it
does maybe come from is just that like
it's harder to make gains period um and
so like
uh I I I sort of I sort of think that
like the
general kind of physiological effect of
a particular dose of training doesn't
necessarily change over time but it just
gets like more and more blunted over
time and so if if you're interested in
like hey how much do I need to do to be
able to like reliably PR after a 12we
training cycle I think that like that
number probably for a lot of people
again I don't think it just like
increases linearly forever but like I do
suspect that that does go up over time
um just cuz like just [__] doing
anything if you're untrained if you
don't PR after 12 weeks like you pick
bad parents and and better luck in the
next life um you know if you've been
training for like a year H like you
probably need to get after it pretty
good but like shouldn't be that bad if
you've been training for like 5 years um
if you're going to PR all lifts after a
12we training cycle like reliably like I
I think that that
requires like really pushing yourself to
the limits with what you can handle just
because like
the uh if you've been training for like
five or 10 years just because kind of
like your Baseline rate of adaptation to
any stimulus is like so much diminished
but like that doesn't necessarily mean
that the amount of volume that's
effective for you has dramatically
changed it's just kind of like if you're
trying to
see like measur able effects on like a
particular time scale if that makes
sense where like you know it it it very
well could be that your your volume
versus strength gains curve has never
changed at any point along the way but
like previously previously it was like
you could put 10 lbs on your squat with
like One X level of volume and 30 lbs on
your squat
with 4X level of volume in 12 weeks but
now it's like you know you could put
half a pound on your squat with with One
X level of volume in 12 weeks or five
pounds on your squat with 5x level of
volume in 12 weeks like you the the
shape of that curve hasn't fundamentally
changed but it's just like if you're
trying to see like a certain amount of
measurable progress like it it gives the
appearance of things like trending up
pretty quickly and so yeah like I I
don't I don't know that that's what is
happening but like I wonder if it is
like I I suspect ected maybe yeah only
one way to find out that is
true let's answer some some listener
questions real quick and then and then
wrap this puppy up how does that sound
to you it sounds amazing all right let's
start with a question from Alish
sha hey Dr pack um just wondering if we
know what's the difference between
maintenance volume and let's say the
minimum effective dose for hypertrophy
so I appreciate the question as far as
maintenance volume for hypertrophy and
minimum effective dose the data on
minimum effective dose if we Define
effective as like
seeing significant um or like meaningful
hypertrophy increases obviously in the
literature for hypertrophy we may have
to look at studies that have defined
meaningfulness as statistical
significance the volume that you need to
make some form of hypertrophy gains that
are deemed meaningful as far as the
literature goes is as low as like one to
three sets per muscle group per week
which which essentially allows me to
feel somewhat confident in saying that
you could maintain muscle mass with as
little as one like intense set per
muscle group a week potentially even
less I know you guys have touched on uh
on this topic in the um in the past on
the podcast where like I wouldn't be
surprised even if you
were even if you did like a few
isometrics or something as as as an
orthodox as that versus your regular
training that you'd still be able to
maintain your muscle mass to a to to a
great extent but for the for the
listener that posed the question I'd say
that one to three sets per muscle group
per week can be thought of as like
maintenance SL like low minimum
effective dose cuz you are like taking a
bit of a chance there as far as
meaningful gains go and as as far as
like a safer bet minimum effective dose
training volume for hypertrophy I would
go somewhere in the three to six sets
per muscle group a week where you can
feel even more confident that you are
making indeed meaningful gains makes
sense so maintenance is about half of
minimum effective dose and minimum
effective doses maybe like uh between
1/ half to 1 depending on someone's like
General volume tolerance like maybe
what's theoretically optimal for like
maximizing rates of progress yeah and I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be worried about
losing gains as if you're going to the
gym and you're doing something like
especially if you're keeping intensity
of effort high if you're not in some
crazy deficit I think it's very
difficult for you to to lose muscle mass
and I think um mrv not mrv um min
maintenance volume is somewhat
overstated or the idea that hey if
you're not matching your previous volume
you're losing gains I think uh we don't
have any evidence to directly support
that idea oh I I think we have evidence
to like pretty strongly refute it yes oh
man I'm blanking on the the name of the
author but that like 20 2011 paper um
like the volume reduction paper where
they had people doing nine sets a week
and then they cut back like the
oh man I'm gonna I'm G to kick myself
I'm blanking I'm blanking on on the
author's name I'll I'll find I'll find
that and put that in the show notes uh
but yeah like they they had people train
for I think it was either like I think
it was 12 weeks and then they reduced
their training volume for the subsequent
12 weeks um and with the young adults in
that study they um they either reduce
the volume by oneir or two 1/3 of their
original volume or 1 nth of their
original volume when they reduced it to
1/3 of their original volume they kept
making gains so clearly you didn't have
to maintain your previous volume to keep
making gains like they cut back still
made progress and like they they
maintained for like another either like
12 or 16 weeks at one nth of their
original volume so yeah yeah like pretty
pretty indisputably I think like
maintenance volume is way lower than the
volume required to actually make gains
yeah it's it's great cuz you I've I've
been hearing you say that for a while
and it's like it's something that I try
to to communicate to lifters where they
get nervous like on holid dayss or
periods of time where they're even more
like they don't have equipment or
whatever I'm like literally anything as
long as there's some form of intensity
of effort just to make sure and you're
covered you're not going to suddenly
start losing muscle mass yeah uh 2011 by
Bickle yeah that'll that'll be in the
show notes the name of the study is
exercise dosing to retain resistance
training adaptations in young and older
adults for anyone who wants to dive in
uh and yeah it was it was two 16 week
phases uh and the other thing to note is
that the older adults in the study did
uh did end up like losing muscle and
strength when they reduced their volume
to 1 nth of what they were doing
previously but like even older adults
were able to maintain for 16 weeks when
reducing their volume to 1/3 of initial
so yeah I mean if if if you're currently
making gains you have you have a very
large cushion to cut back and still
maintain what you currently have for
sure all right shall I play the next
question yes sir uh next question from
Ross to what extent could your minimum
effective dose results be explained by
tapering or peaking I believe in the
study these were not alltime PRS but
pre/post
could the pre- results just be coming
off the back of more fatigue and less
specific
work is there data on how the minimum
effective dose protocol would perform if
initiated immediately after a D Lo from
a peak 1 RM
test um excellent question and that's
one of the limitations that I think we
should have we should have addressed
more in the paper and I think it would
have been interesting if we actually
noted the participants alltime PRS cuz I
personally knew some of the participants
and they some did hit alltime PRS some
others didn't uh and that was a a really
solid question in the sense that you
know um seeing if you were to test my
deadlift today and then have me do a
minimum dose sort of protocol for 6
weeks I may not hit my all-time best
deadlift today and I may actually
surpass my alltime surpass my pre-
deadlift in six weeks but still be below
my all-time
best however
I would still say that although it could
be explained part partly due to peaking
um or some form of uh some form of
fatigue dissip
dissipation um at the same time I don't
see
why if if those lifters were able to see
strength increases in six weeks I don't
see how you could you could uh
necessarily work around that limit ation
without really really factoring in all
their previous training experience peing
them and then having them follow such a
protocol if that makes sense um so if
they're able to make meaningful strength
gains in just in six weeks it may be
that they can continue making set gains
um for for a while longer if we were to
extend the duration of the study if if I
could just add something though I I do
think that that is a fair critique of
your study but not a critique that is
unique to your study um cuz like that
that question could be directed to any
study on trained lifters because you're
not going to get it's it's not going to
be the case that everyone who enrolls in
your study is at their all-time
strongest so that is a limitation of
your research but that's also a
limitation of all of the research on
trained so I don't I don't see why it
would be like particularly applicable to
your research more than any others mhm
exactly like to be extremely clear like
I don't think I don't think Ross was
doing this but I do think that there are
a set of uh extremely valid like
Evergreen universally applicable um
criticisms that one could use to
question the method ological quality of
almost any resistance training study
that takes place um and I do sometimes
see a
willingness may even desire to level
those criticisms at steady results that
someone either disagrees with or finds
unintuitive um without necessarily
leveling those same criticisms at
studies that they agree with or do find
intuitive and so I would I would call
ction against that a little bit like you
know like Mo most most studies don't
control for subjects like alltime levels
of
strength not most studies I'm not aware
of a single study that that has uh
exactly like factored that in or like
ensured that every subject recruited was
at their all-time strongest when they
enrolled in the study um or like you
know another Evergreen criticism is like
oh well maybe these results were driven
by novelty like whatever training
intervention was that was used was like
different enough than what people were
doing before or like like such that the
actual
experimental um manipulation didn't lead
to the results but like an interaction
between that manipulation and the
people's prior training uh led to the
results which you know is is like
similar to what Ross was asking like the
the question of like were people
tapering and peeking does like
necessarily kind of assume that their
previous volumes were higher their or
this was a step down in volume so they
were tapering but yeah like that that is
the case for like again like almost all
studies like very very few of them
really like robustly account for that
which like you could you could um just
make it standard so that you have like a
four to eight week runin where everyone
does a standardized training program
before then splitting them up down two
different tracks of training but it's
just not feasible cuz like like we
talked about about before you have a
finite amount of time to run a study
just because of how semesters
work yeah recruiting 30 people like 32
people across three studies that's
including the pilot study took like
three three years in total maybe
slightly less plus covid came as well at
some point but like that population I'd
rather have that limitation and be able
to include them then have dropouts
because like three dropouts make make a
difference when you're only dealing with
like nine people per group because
you're looking at like trained
powerlifters yeah I don't know kind of
like long long story short for me and
again to reiterate for like the third
time I don't I don't think Ross was
leveling like an unfair criticism
against your paper like I I do think
that this was like a question asked in
good faith but
like that is a a type of question that I
often see asked in I think bad faith um
where where there's there there are
probably like I don't want to overstate
it but there's probably like half a
dozen like literally Evergreen critiques
one could make of a study and this this
was one of them like were the
results potentially influenced by the
prior training that the subjects were
doing and therefore you can't make
inferences about the actual experimental
manipulation you did because it's
actually driven by what they were doing
beforehand which was uncontrolled which
like yeah sure like it I I think it's
entirely possible that that influenced
the result you saw but that is also
something that could influence the
results of every study ever done on
trained lifters and it's just kind of a
a limitation you have to accept yeah and
that's why that's where the interview uh
data comes in somewhat handy plus the
the anecdotes that have been like I have
not seen many if I've seen very few
people come out um in the past couple of
years when the concept of the minimum
Doge gained a bit more traction and say
that's BS um i' I've tried training with
lower volumes and I've had the worst
results of my life it's been quite the
opposite as far as anecdotes go and
people saying oh you know I've managed
to hit some solid PRS uh when I actually
toned down the volume when I was super
busy or whatever but if the data is
somewhat matched by what experienced
coaches and athletes say sure some
limitations and some terms and
conditions apply but I do think that the
majority of lifters would probably see
meaningful gains um in 6 to 12 weeks
doing very specific um minimum dose
powerlifting training I
agree all right moving on to the
questions that came in uh in the
Facebook group and subreddit uh we have
two from the subreddit most of the
questions on the Facebook group were
directed to Milo for the episode that we
will be recording next week so we got
two questions from the subreddit here
for pack uh the first is by kill chop 66
six uh he says Hey pack when working at
a minimal effective dose does frequency
matter more or less to give a practical
example if I only have three training
days and want to do the bare minimum for
my legs does it matter if I spread the
movement throughout the three days or if
I just hit one bigger leg day and get it
over with yeah so allow me to press say
real doctors and quote the paper whom
should we really call a doctor by Abdul
fat um where he and I quote says when we
are asked in a Physicians or dentist's
office what kind of doctor we are we
respond the real one um that aside
actual quote actual paper and I wasn't
aware that people would take the real
doctor joke seriously um I think based
on the data from our studies where
people did deadlift they deadlifted once
per week um it didn't seem that
frequency made a huge huge deal like
they made they made great gains for the
deadlift if not uh it maybe and let me
just pull up the actual the actual data
as far as changes in the the deadlift
goes if you look at the data um it
pretty much looks the same if not better
than um than the squat at least for the
the groups that did the back off sets as
well than the squat and the bench press
and the bench press was the lift that
was performed with the highest frequency
so I don't think it plays that huge of a
rle keep in mind that frequency here was
determined solely by my experience as a
coach where you know you usually see
that the the deadlift performed less
frequently than the squad and the squad
performed less frequently than the bench
so I wanted to create sort of a protocol
that sort of mimicked um real life uh
conditions so if you have just three
training days and you want to do the
bare minimum for your for your legs I
don't think that it would as long as you
can get in quality the volume and
whatnot and it feels great I don't think
that it matters that much if you spread
the the the workload throughout the week
versus doing one bigger leg day and
getting it over with yeah I I agree with
that I I
do I tend to think that frequency
matters more as volumes get higher and
higher um and I I I wonder if that's
more like practical than physiological
like if you're trying to get 30 sets in
for quads per week like it's going to be
rough in one session like spread it over
three h it's still going to be rough but
like your your setby set quality isn't
going to go to [__] like as much by the
end of the workout but if you're doing
three sets you're going to get three
pretty good sets whether you're doing
that one set three days or all three on
one day so eh yeah I I I agree that it's
probably not that big of a deal uh our
final question here is by gowans 5 who
says hey low volume is all the hype
these days so it had me thinking I've
heard that you should only add volume
when you stop making progress my
question is would you start someone at 6
to 10 sets per week and only add volume
when necessary to continue making
progress or would you start with a
moderate amount of volume and adjust up
or down based on how you're feeling to
try to determine at what volume you
might personally make the best progress
with at that point in time the second
option would require you to probably
adjust intensity fre quy or proximity to
failure rather than just increasing
volume when you're not seeing progress
which obviously requires more
troubleshooting so kind of a statement
slash question but uh B basically just
asking kind of like how you would
manipulate volume over time um when it
seems that someone maybe stops
progressing kind of like what's what's
your move yeah so coaches uh Coach's
Corner um over here like as a coach if
it would depend on the individual's
goals so if you were a powerlifter
competitive powerlifter and you are like
look this means a lot to me I want to
make the most I I can make out of my
training it's uh it's likely that we
wouldn't start at the lower end of a
minimum effective training uh volume
let's assume that all your lifts uh you
don't have any sort of anomalous um
requirements for your lifts as far as
volume goes where you tell me hey pack
historic
if I do more than x amount of sets for
the deadlift my Squad Squad training
goes to trash as you mentioned Greg
right um so assuming that things are
relatively relatively um consistent or
at least normal I would start at a
slightly higher training volume so more
than than the minimum effective training
dose for that individual and then adjust
from there onwards dto for
hypertrophy but uh if you're somebody
with more sort of you're not a
competitive strength or physique athlete
I would start somewhere in the middle
where we will be monitoring things like
session RP and estimated eana Rams as
well as how you're feeling and how
things are looking on from a not not
just a week toe basis but like on a
month-to-month basis as far as strength
increases go and if we see that over
time you are feeling relatively fresh
after each session and you're like
hitting a session RP of like 2 to three
out of uh the highest being seven that's
where I would be adding more training
volume same goes for hypertrophy and for
hypertrophy Things become even more
difficult to assess as far as gains go
so if we're seeing performance increase
increase on a multitude of lifts and rep
ranges and you seem to be fresh enough
to still do more and you're trying to
absolutely maximize hypertrophy there's
a chance that over time we would we
would be adding the odd set here and
there but in a less drastic um sort of
um approach versus if you're somebody
who is like really really not uh feeling
like you're getting fatigued after
workouts if you're like hey this was a
piece of cake I got in and out I barely
felt like I trained that's where I would
potentially push volume even more but if
you're somewhere in the middle and you
feel that the workouts are challenging
and things are progressing chances are
um that we would keep volume relatively
Conant for quite a bit of time before we
add even more sets yeah I I I agree with
that as time goes on I sort of think
there are less there are fewer and fewer
kind of hard rules and
heuristics like the the first kind of
setup was I've heard that you should
only add volume when you stop making
progress um and asking like should you
only should you start at some level and
only add volume when necessary um I I
think that like I think that that is
based on
on a supposition a lot of people have um
that I I I know where it's coming from
but I think it's completely wrong um
like the idea is essentially that you
have some some sort of like fixed
variable called volume tolerance and
that uh sort of as alluded to previously
in this episode the idea being that like
as your volume gets higher and higher
that volume tolerance uh
increases such that you you need at
least the current level of volume to
keep making progress and if you were to
drop back like you would get weaker or
uh get weaker at worst or fail to make
gains at best um and like there there's
just plenty of like experimental
evidence suggesting that's not true just
like like the the Bickle study for
instance like you're you're making gains
you cut your volume by 2/3 you keep
making gains like maybe not quite as
fast as before but is that because your
volume tolerance had gone down or just
kind of like even if you were starting
from from scratch you would have made
slower gains with onethird of the the
volume that you trained with previously
like I think it's more the latter than
the former um so yeah like I I think I
think it depends a lot on what someone's
goals are and just kind of like the
training variables they respond best to
like in in my experience some people do
just really Thrive with higher volume
and some folks don't like you start
ramping it up and they get really
fatigued really quickly and so yeah if
if someone doesn't really get worn down
by higher volumes and they really seem
to thrive on it I wouldn't be
conservative about trying to start them
with like a low volume and like
gradually build them up it's like hey
like you you do well with higher volumes
I can start you with higher volumes you
know and like if we if we need to
increase from there cool and also if we
ever overreach like I feel pretty
confident that we can we can pull back
and you're not going to regress uh by by
doing so because I I think that if if
volume tolerance exists it it has much
more to do with like your ability to
recover from the volume you're doing
versus physiologically needing a ton of
volume to continue progress like I I
think that those are two distinct things
and I think higher volumes do improve
your ability to tolerate higher volumes
I don't necessarily think that they
rapidly if at all increase the threshold
of volume you need to clear to keep
making gains like I could be totally
wrong about that but like that's that's
kind of how I feel about it I agree so
yeah I I wouldn't necessarily start low
and build up for everyone all the time
and there are also plenty of instances
like you Ed to pack where if someone
stalls my first thought wouldn't be
let's increase volume you know like that
that's another thing where where it a
lot of it just has to do with like
knowing your lifter or if you're
managing your own training knowing
yourself you know it could it could be
more a matter of like manipulating
frequency it could be more a matter of
like subbing lifts in and out could be a
matter of manipulating intensity like
there there are plenty of there are
plenty of knobs you could turn to try to
make progress again if you fit a plateau
other than just manipulating volume so
ah that may be kind of a copout answer
but it I do think it is like quite
context dependent but I I'm I'm not I'm
not afraid to start someone with like
moderate to high volume uh for a certain
training block if I know that they do
pretty well with moderate to high volume
yeah same totally totally agree and you
shouldn't be that fearful of uh fatigue
building like I saw that comment um some
somewhere else where it's like hey what
what if I cross in the Red Zone where
I'm in my maximum recoverable volume
like you will know when you're overdoing
it and the the only thing you need to do
is take a couple of steps back and
that's it you're not going to randomly
find yourself overt trining and in at
hospital just because you did a bit more
than you could recover from worst case
scenario you'll be a bit more sore and
you'll have to readjust your training in
the next couple of weeks yeah no I I
agree I also think a conceptual model
that has done a great disservice to a
lot of people who who do kind of like
get into the theory of this stuff is is
the idea that um the relationship
between volume and hypertrophy has like
an inverted you
relationship I think people interpret
that like too literally like I like I do
I do think that it is I think that it's
a nonlinear relationship uh that you
know it does have like a downward facing
shape like it has like a downward
inflection um but I don't think it it's
particularly close to you shape and I
think like not like I I don't want to
sound like I'm throwing people who use
that term under the bus cuz like I
suspect a lot of the like Educators that
use that term are using it kind of
loosely where it's not like strictly
parabolic you know it's just a it just
signifies the general idea of like hey
you're not going to make maximal gains
with like super low volume
gains usually increases volume increases
and then you keep going up eventually it
Peters out and and it might go negative
at some point but I I think that that
rightward tale is a pretty long tale um
and so yeah like I I think I think
people often get the idea that with kind
of like a strict literal interpretation
of that inverted U relationship they
think that like oh man like I'm training
like I I feel like I'm training pretty
hard but I'm not currently making
progress therefore I'm currently like
teetering right on uh the the rightward
uh x intercept of that graph
yeah and so like if if I push it a
little more like I'm going to over train
and like start regressing um and like I
I think I think in effect there's
probably a pretty [__] Hefty Dead
Zone there where if you went back 10% or
if you increased by like another 40%
like like you're fine it's probably just
not it's probably just not going to do
anything like like to get to get to the
point where that curve actually goes
negative and you're meaningfully losing
muscle and strength at like a relatively
cognizable rate like a pretty fast speed
on like you know numbers are going down
on like measurable time scales and not
just like in an acute fatigue way but
kind of like in a durable way where even
after you d load performance is going to
be down like 20 30 pounds like
like you I I really think you have to
[__] try to get there like if you
have to actively fight you have to wake
up every day and be like okay ibuprofen
cold shower like ice baths uh and like
caffeinate yourself to the to the to the
the bone and just like force yourself to
to to do these workouts like you yeah I
I I just I just don't think you're
getting there by
accident and the literature like once
you look at the volume literature
closely and you're like wait a second
there's there are there is you know the
evidence is mounding for 30 30 plus sets
per muscle group per week where you're
still seeing growth even in the infamous
52 set study that you're going to touch
on in detail with with Milo probably
it's like those guys did an average of
37 sets for their quads per week and
they kept seeing growth they didn't
Plateau they saw more growth than the
other groups there's a there's a cool
meta in the works by the Robinson Nal
aka the guys over at data driven
strength that will be coming out um at
some point in the future in the near
future on training volume I won't spoil
the results because they they're not
fully done with their analysis yet but
I'm I'm I'm we may see that you know
more is more and up to an extent that
people haven't really considered before
yeah hot takes for the few that are
still here with us that doesn't surprise
me to hear um I I am going to ask you
about that more when we get done
recording this this is just me becoming
like kudin Le again I guess but like uh
a consistent point of frustration for me
is just like how
much how much it seems like discourse is
driven by like extremely rough
conceptual models yeah um and you can
say like hey well there's there's data
that says this and they're like well but
that
this this model disagrees with that
outcome it's like
well in science going back to the idea
of like scientific epistemology like
usually you build theories with recourse
to the data and if new data is published
that disagrees with a theory like
obviously not just like one study you
don't want to like throw the baby out
with the with the bath water like I I
don't want to I don't want to make it
sound like I'm a naive paparian but like
the idea of falsification has to be at
some point like if if the theory like if
the data conform to the theory it's
probably a pretty good theory if enough
data don't conform to a theory the
problem the problem is with the theory
not the data um like insulin model of
obesity for
example responding to data with saying
well it doesn't disagree with the theory
that's that's not a reputation of the
data like you you don't realize it but
you're refuting the theory that you're
trying to argue in favor of
preach that's a good place to wrap it up
nice nice low note to end on I'm good at
that uh pack do you have uh do you have
any any final thoughts or last words for
the good people listening not really I
thoroughly enjoyed that if you guys have
any questions um regarding anything we
talked about feel free to reach out um
via the DMS on Instagram or I guess
Twitter or Formerly Known Aster so now
known as X um but yeah it's been a
pleasure thank you for coming on uh and
and where can uh where can the people
reach you and or do you have anything
that you would like to plug on the way
out the door so I do have a YouTube
channel uh if you type Dr do. Pak pack
on YouTube that should pop up people can
reach me on Instagram I am not on
Facebook so again same thing Dr Pac on
Instagram drore PAC because the other
iterations were not available and if you
want some free minimum dose uh templates
you can go to minimum Doos training.com
yes I have purchased multiple minimum
dose domain names and for the literature
minimum dose. trining um yeah that's it
sounds great thanks P have a good one
thank you all right thanks for listening
to another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast uh we we deeply
appreciate all of you and we're we're
very excited to be back on on our normal
posting schedule uh as mentioned
multiple times in this episode uh we
will have another episode of the Pod
coming out in two weeks that one with uh
Dr Milo wolf so hope you enjoyed this
one and uh hope we will see
Slash have have another parasocial
interaction with you again for the next
one as well thanks for listening
[Music]
goodbye